dans l'émission du 28 octobre 2000 j'ai
interviewé christine orban sur son livre
l'origine du monde et j'ai dit lors de
cette interview que louis pauwels et son
épouse elin à la bourdette posséder un
cinéma porno c'est pas parfaitement
exact en fait ils possédaient un
immeuble dans lequel il y avait un
cinéma et ce cinéma avait été
transformée à leur insu en cinéma porno
et dès qu'ils ont su ça ils ont fait
tout leur possible pour expulser le
gérant du cinéma porno donc elina
labourdette ne possédez pas un cinéma
porno dont acte désolé l'ina
[Musique]
on ne compte pas il voit la radio et
vous dit quelques mois ce matin j'avais
l'impression que tout le monde et vous
déplacer
[Applaudissements]
sur le plateau de tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle vous connaissez l'équipe wasyl ans
ma fille
[Applaudissements]
laurent baffie bonsoir alors sexe
magouille et culture générale au gymnase
à partir du 30 janvier 2001 avec bernard
farcy pascal sellem pascal sellem mado
maurin géraldine bonnet gains et voit la
super comédienne c'est quoi le pix le
pitch est un jeu télé le plus grand jeu
culturel de la plus grande chaîne de
télé française et avec un type qui pour
un producteur véreux qui a eu la chance
d'hériter de la production de ce jeu il
ya une mamie 80 balais qui est
omniscient t qui gagne tout depuis 18
semaines et cette grand-mère a passionné
la france par son avenir et érudition et
quelques temps après commence à ennuyer
tout le monde pascal baylon 18 semaines
un fil directeur de la chaîne dit aux
producteurs soit le jeu remonte soit je
confie d'apprendre à quelqu'un d'autre
peut maintenant chhabiyé va passer à
quelqu'un d'autre
donc le producteur va tout mettre en
oeuvre pour virer la vieille comédie et
les réservations ça va incroyable avant
moi je plaisantais je pensais pas que
les gens allaient acheter des poules
vous avez par tue pas encore directoire
je veux revenir à par l'amba vie je
recevrai ce soir
jean hugues anglade
obiwi
maintien
alléluia
didier gustin
anne vallée noire
richier
brentel monsieur j
une cartier messieurs
bon ça karting pour le blind test par
équipes à la fin de l'émission
alors maintenant on passe aux meilleurs
de l'émission précédente ça s'appelle
tout le monde en a parlé c'est préparé
par jean hugues noël la ruelle bendit to
search qui était marié non c'est pas
très rond avec la championne du monde de
bodybuilding
est-ce que physiquement excusez moi
c'est un peu un discret comme question
est ce qu'elle est excité physiquement
parce que c'est une montagne de muscles
c'est une ans était pas elle c'est pas
du tout ça
la mort ce qui veut dire ils n'osent pas
le dire parce qu'au fond il est timide y
est est-ce que c'est pas un truc de [ __ ]
de se taper une culture histoire
est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
je me souviens je me souviens j'étais il
y avait une petite place un arrêt de bus
et gisait au revoir à ce garçon c'était
mon premier baiser avec la langue je me
suis retourné j'ai regardé mes copines
mais j'ai fait
première cuite c'est ça au monde appelle
le bernard émond qu'un ravaillac 2000
par exemple si l'arrivée et qui vous
tuer thierry mois serait bien à la mer a
jamais pourquoi on ne bouge pas la rampe
à qui a essayé le secret est enfermé
dans mon coffre à la banque dans une
enveloppe scellée qu'on ouvrira à ma
mort alors une tumeur alors un mais
c'est vrai que j'ai marqué que vos
parents sont blancs et que les votes
sont noirs et ça vous fait rigoler c'est
un mensonge
ah oui il faut dire quand on s'est vus
faut dire non à ces interviews mensonge
pas dire le contraire de la vérité
oui et vous ils sont noirs c'est évident
vient alors asia argento est ce que vous
êtes gérant tôt ça dépend de l'âge
cinquante deux ans ces vieux 52 ans
alors oui voilà et ben voilà est grand
amateur de deux femmes et l'alcool tout
le monde le sait non ce n'est pas un
secret pendant dire grand amateur de
femmes et d'alcool c'est sexiste bon
alors je donne le talent a dit boucher
toutes les choses de la vie dont les
femmes et l'alcool ça va ça
est vrai jamais j'aimais bien baisés
boire non mais je sais moi ça me gêne
mais dire ça à moi personnellement
j'aurais dit vous êtes un grand amateur
d'alcool et de femmes
je sais je sais mais chaque hausse de 10
à peine de 11 ans devenu donc enfin vous
champion du monde des constructeurs et
schumacher champion du monde des pilotes
voilà pas non plus
gallois
elle a parlé et
là maintenant
[Musique]
voilà
l'alternance
il est parfait en occident le lien des
films de jean jacques beineix mortel
transfert
voici jean hugues anglade
jean hugues anglade bonsoir timbre est
d'abord à toutes les filles qui me
disent toujours dans cette émission il
est super gonzesses
il n'y a jamais de beau mais quand je
signale qu'à lui samuel le bihan il ya
jean hugues anglade baladeur bâle a su
comment ça va très bien merci
déjà à peine il arrive il ya déjà un
malaise bien alors jean hugues anglade
en plus vous vous êtes vous avez une
qualité c'est qu'on peut dire que vous
vous êtes pas beaucoup de problèmes pour
mettre tout nu parce que j'ai en grève
commence fort non mais au printemps 80
en clôture du conservatoire vous êtes nu
sur scène dans tête d'or de claudel déjà
commencé très fort dès l'école quoi oui
et vous n'avez jamais eu tellement de
problèmes en fait j'ai pas de saper j'ai
pas de problème pour me montrer nue
vas-y là il se dit alors est-ce qu'ils
vont me demander le pas tout de suite à
la fin à la fin de l'émission à dix mois
votre premier film dont 82 ça s'appelait
l'indiscrétion de pierre larry et vous
aimez pas en parler pourquoi
non c'était parce que c'était 2
j'étais comme un jeune acteur assez
j'avais le trac et sap a été fait sa
part est un film qui s'est déroulée dans
le plaisir
votre premier film vous considérez que
c'est quoi c'est l'homme et c'est
l'homme blessé c'est l'année d'après 183
patrice chéreau vous avez une carrière
étonnante vous avez fait plein de films
en fait donc l'homme blessé qu'un film
très très sensible très beau en 85
subway de besson en 86 évidemment 37 2
le matin de beineix déjà 89 une
magnifique d'alain corneau nocturne
indien 90 nikita besson 94 killing zoe
donc aussi la même année la reine margot
toujours chéreau et en 96 vous écrivez
vous réalisez ton cas avec votre
compagne de l'époque pamela sous vous
l'avez rencontrée à l'enseignement vous
l'avez rencontré six ans avant de faire
le film
alors que vous devez signer le le
personnage c'est incroyable cette
histoire oui j'avais déjà commencé à
écrire les premiers traits du personnage
est effectivement par une coïncidence
assez heureux je les rencontre et de
deux ans après le début de mon écriture
c'est fou ça bah oui je sais pas si
c'est fou en tout cas c'est bien vous
arrivez à un soir aux bains douches
oui c'est votre personnage est là devant
vous oui ça a dû vous faire un choc
ça m'a fait ça m'a fait bizarre mais
j'étais j'étais content qu'il y ait
après le film la question qui vient à
l'esprit dans ces cas là c est ce qu
après le film une fois le film terminé
est-ce que l'existant encore où est ce
que c'était simplement le personnage du
film et puis voilà le film terminé je
crois qu'elle existait par certains
traits de son caractère toujours mais le
après je me suis marié avec elle et et
voilà j'ai récemment divorcée donc voir
quel papa et sa vie privée sa durée par
ben wallace et c'est tous et ses
finalités de la fin d'une belle aventure
mais et de niro l'avait draguer à calan
94 me souviens j'étais le dernier au
courant d'ailleurs c'était à l'époque de
la deûle à delà de la reine margot mais
je m'en suis pas vraiment rendu compte
et je crois en plus que les que les
journaux à scandale j'en ai assez facile
ont un peu quand même amplifié wii ne
s'est rien passé
rassurez-nous je crois non je ne crois
pas bon ou bien alors maintenant il ya
effectivement ma fille laurent pour
jean-louis que je fais parce que je les
aime bien vas-y alors mortel transfert
donc de beineix avec hélène de
fougerolles yves rénier formidable dans
le film robert hirsch catherine mouchet
et denis podalydès qui fait l'inspecteur
de police au passage j'aimerais vous
remercier à ce que toute l'équipe est
très touchée vous défendiez le film
puisque vous avez déjà invité hélène de
fougerolles
mais pour en parler aujourd'hui où
l'invité non mais c'est un film qu'on
aime bien très contente c'est pas facile
parce que c'est vrai qu'au chaigne à
l'aja son ca serait bien qu'ils sont ici
[Musique]
c'est l'otan c'est d'autant mieux qu'en
fait pas un film c'est pas comme
l'audimat cela ne se vérifie pas la
seconde près un film ça demande du temps
pour s'installer et que là on est en
train d'assister un retour de deux
tendances et d'un bon bouche à oreille
c'est vrai qu'au départ
après ça a été un peu comme ça il ya la
vraie chaîne n'a pas vraiment et dice
est vrai que malgré tout le film
maintenant est en train de de marquer
des points et on est très on est très
confiants et jean-jacques va se battre
jusqu'au bout pour que le film existe un
petit soldat belle axa tous les matins
il part au combat lien oui c'est même un
grand soldat réelles belgique tous ces
jeux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mortel transfert de jean jacques beineix
avec jean hugues anglade qui est notre
invité ce soir
alors vous jouez le rôle de michel
durand en psychanalyse qui a une vie
plutôt banale il est là en train de
recevoir des clients il ya catherine
mouche et qui sait une prof de maths
chahuté qui est excellente dans le rôle
d'ailleurs puis à l'éjaculation précoce
qui est toujours énervé et puis lé récit
sado-maso de d'hélène de fougerolles
donc qui joue olga kugler et qui est une
perverse cleptomane qu'elle se faire
battre par son mari qui yves rénier
voilà et que se passe-t-il
oui j'avais oublié un principe de
l'émission est ce parce que à ce
psychanalyste est quand même un peu
dépressif et il est absolument convaincu
que cette cette patiente et said éveillé
en lui des désirs meurtrier et il a la
fâcheuse tendance à s'endormir quand
elle vient le consulter et un jour il
s'endort elle se réveille et elle est
morte sur son divan est il à d'horribles
douleur dans les avant bras
donc voilà alors peut-on assassiner
quelqu'un endormante la première
question qu'on se pose et ensuite comme
l'a très vite comment se débarrasser du
corps oui et donc toute une histoire
commence une histoire effectivement très
ça fait un peu penser aux films de deux
scores cc qui s'appelait fera world
series bien le type il est pris dans une
espèce de l'engrenage comme ça c'est un
peu cet esprit là oui absolument il
aurait la possibilité d'appeler tout de
suite la police est finalement il fait
le mauvais choix ou le bon choix en
cernant finalement à l'arrivée on
s'aperçoit que ce film c'est aussi le
parcours initiatique d'un psy d'un psy
au fond qui qui va régler des comptes
avec lui mais en fait son analyse à lui
parce que tu pourrais tout il faut avoir
fait une analyse mais lui son analyse
commence au début du show commence aussi
bien finalement ils obligés de regarder
les programmes qu'ils n'avaient pas
réglé les actes - c'est ça l'histoire
tout à fait joséphine psy ou n'ont
jamais non non non non vous et l envoi
rend là pour préparer le film où il
enfin j'ai vu que j'ai pu j'ai vu peu de
gens j'ai vu une personne qui m'a donné
deux phrases clés qui l'écoutent
flottante et la neutralité bienveillante
non mais en fin de compte je sais il a
été il atterrit khelladi muller
non j'ai pas vu mon nom j'en ai
rencontré un beaucoup plus intéressant
et neutralité bienveillante et écoute
flottante voilà ça c'est le b à ba du
psy ces prix en fête du travail avec
l'acteur vis-à-vis de ses personnages
alors votre père était vétérinaire et
finalement vous avez intégré un peu
inconsciemment les codes du en voyant ça
peut-être dans les codes du patient vie
des malades etc
oui si élégant qui vont jusqu'à
l'arrivée de voir justement et qu'on
manquait de costumes
choper des monts bref je ne pourrais pas
te le dis je vous ai déjà fait des rôles
de médecins avaient déjà fait dix mois
oui qu'a dit la ligue 1 bordeaux ray et
donc vous avez est ce que cela vient de
me gilbert place chez les animaux avec
leur avec leurs maîtres et puis j'en ai
conçu surtout une très très grande
passion pour le monde animal jamais dans
les zaouïas rab
là vous avez quelqu'un le sait que
laurent à laurent et zoophiles c'est
incroyable comment on dit quelqu'un qui
aime bien les animaux grâce à cécile
zoophiles à un blog mais alors jean
hugues anglade lui c'est laisser les
félins oui c'est les guépards oui ces
policiers par le chant du guépard tout
le monde connaît même fait tatouer
déconner tu veux le voir à laon à la
hausse
là on a dit on a dit à la fin d'émission
alors les filles à la fin de l'émission
jean hugues anglade boubon si vous
suivez toujours
si vous êtes toujours là vous verrez le
guépard de gens rigolent bien alors vous
allez retrouver hélène de fougerolles
que vous aviez déjà vu dans trois
régions de jardin elle a de l'avenir
vous pensé parce que tout le monde lui
prédit un grand avenir mais en même
temps elle n'a pas encore trouvé le
parce que là elle meurt vite dans le
foot de bénesse c'est quelqu'un qui a
l'audace pour pouvoir effectivement
brasser des puits des personnages
difficile et et voilà donc elle est un
peu l est au début mais pas mal mais
elle est très audacieuse de l'axé du mal
avec elle quand même parce qu'elle n'a
pas voulu n'a voulu rien montré oui ella
ella ella négocier très réglo mais je
pense que c'est se montrer nue n'est pas
forcément un signe
extraversion la preuve en est ce que moi
je suis pas particulièrement fan suis
plutôt timide de nature timide effacée
de bord je me suis mis devenu un déficit
élevé
vous avez une plastique exceptionnel
bien alors vous avez retrouvé beineix
assez intéressant parce que 37 2 le
matin comme était un film c'est toujours
un film culte
vous l'avez retrouvé comment oui bah je
les retrouver par hasard ce qui m'a
appelé 15 ans après un nom que j'ai
gardé un tel souvenir de 37,2 bon c'est
une banalité de que de le dire encore
aujourd'hui met d'ailleurs en j'en
profite pour dire que le dvd en version
intégrale intégrale de 37,2 va sortir là
est déjà sorti je plante ce que j'ai
appris sur sur mortel transfert est
davantage j'ai davantage regarder jean
jacques et la façon dont il avait évolué
la façon dont il s'était aguerris et
puis la maturité qui est la sienne
aujourd'hui son indépendance son courage
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que ce film
est
c'est lui qui l'a produit encore une
fois c'est vraiment très courageux et
c'est encore la raison pour laquelle je
pense que la critique et la critique
était très dur avec lui parce que elle
devrait tenir compte de la courage qui a
été le sien de produire ce film il a mis
son argent
il aimait son argent et sa wii vous
pouvez l'acquérir pour une fois qu'un
producteur tumulte en argent à lui c'est
tellement il ya un peu d'argent de canal
est un peu d'argent allemand qu'en
faisant il a mis beaucoup d'argent à lui
voilà alors vous quand vous parlez de
votre travail
c'est vrai que c'est très différent d'un
un film sur l'autre et vous dites j'ai
pas une petite valise remplie de
recettes et j'ai pas encore trop de
combines je fais le maximum pour rester
vierge face à un rôle mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas marqué dans un type de
rôle particulier non non je suis proche
d'un réacteur vous me direz m'enfin je
ne crois pas non mais c'est pas trop à
moi de le dire
ah bon je vous la nouvelle qui pour le
dire non mais c'est à dire que c'est
c'est un métier très très empirique
c'est une approche très très atypique
c'est très difficile et aussi
passionnant bien alors ça s'appelle
mortel transfert de jean jacques beineix
avec hélène de fougerolles jean hugues
anglade et c'est dans un cinéma près de
chez vous
[Musique]
quand vous faites le vous faites le psy
dans le film ben vous allez avoir droit
à une interview psy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez bougé oui je vous dit tout sur
cette émission avait pourtant je la suis
un bon rallume dans sa laurent vous avez
été exemplaire tu toi moi heures tu as
été exemplaire vous citiez attention
interview psy on bouge pas pendant le
guignol bonne réponse de curieux en
dessous je réponds à caroline qui n'ont
rien email en dix ans fait toujours
l'interview psya défi ben non je la fais
un garçon et c'est beaucoup plus
excitant
est ce que vous êtes parano par exemple
n'ont pas bnf quand il a lancé son fils
me l'a dit la chasse au bénin que s'est
ouverte alors tout le monde à les
mélanger pas de chasse au bénin ex et
personne ne l'a vu encore donc c'est un
peu de la parano est ce que vous vous
êtes un peu comme ça à croire que tout
le monde vous déteste tous oui non non
non non je pense pas non non non mais
par rapport à jean jacques je pense que
il ya des gens qui l'attendait au conte
avec un couteau quand même avec quand
même penser que c'est vrai mais non je
ne sais quelle raison la la je pense au
contraire même qu'il a été très sucré
très spirituel paramore d'accord à cette
phrase est ce que c'est ce qu'ils au nom
claustro oui c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs que je ne fais pas de théâtre
ouais et
même au gymnase même ses prix le gymnase
s'est pris pour trois ans je vous êtes
exhibo oui non pas trop
vous n'êtes pas exhibo non pas tant que
ça magnéto serge vous êtes nympho oui
pas forcément que jamais j'aime me
tapait beaucoup de femmes mais j'aime
bien refaire plusieurs fois oui c'est
dur assène fétiche au bas panaro à
chaque fois sa salle au nom pas bon non
vous aimez pas seulement aux mots
vais-je été violée à l'âge de 13 ans par
un pédophile donc avant c'est vrai j'ai
du mal dans ce cas là je savais pas ça
mais non personne ne le savait ça
c'était fils après un vote je le dis je
suis sur le cul
c'est pas vrai c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
c'est bien c'est courageux de dire ça
parce que si vous applaudissez trop ça
va encourager les pédophiles en même
temps ces courageuses qui fait et ce
sera à doser quoi mais qu'on arrête là
parce que non pourquoi non têtards d'eau
oui ça m'arrive
ouais c'est honteux comme un peu tu mon
coco non ayrault non adamo oui mais
enfin il ya bien longtemps
bernardo secchi pas de zorro sur mu et
de nador bien si vous êtes disco non
jean lelong de la dentelle frère de jean
jacques beineix avec hélène
et maintenant mesdames messieurs
j'accueille une autre actrice du film
mortel transfert
ses hobbies
willy bonsoir vous avez 20 ans vous avez
déjà fait vingt films x professionnels
22 22
c'est encore mieux et vous avez aussi un
deug de philo vous l'avez eue à l'âge de
18 ans c'est pour ça qu'on vous appelle
19 les malades les chiffres ouais et
vous avez fait 1 68% et c'est pour ça
qu'on vous appelle l'intello du x6 je
n'ai pas forcément voulu mais on
m'appelle l'intello du x est un fait
ouais bah oui c'est la seule à mon avis
qui est un dock de philo quand même oui
mais bon c'est vrai que je trouve ça un
peu péjoratif et intellos du x parce que
ça voudrait dire que sous prétexte que
j'ai un bac de philo je suis plus
intelligent que les autres alors que
alors que les chaînes doivent en fait
bien alors vous dites je suis une sex
worker c'est assez bien alors du temps
plus que 22 films en deux ans c'est rien
du tout parce que si j'avais choisi
n'importe quoi j'aurais pu en faire une
centaine un film se tourne dans cinq
jours et cinq nuits maximum maximum
maximum vous avez finalement été très
raisonnable très bien choisi vos rôles
et vous êtes devenu en très peu de temps
une star du x est vrai nom il ya quand
même d'envié plein dedans je veux
maintenant avant de vivre un chiffre
gaffe à ce que je dis 202 commencé à 18
ans j'ai attendu d'être majeur alors il
ya trois promo pour vous donc vous allez
faire trois fois ça vous allez voir une
fois
deux fois
laurent votre mauvais esprit vous perdra
dans le gymnase c'est plus la peine
d'aller réserver ses complets jusqu'au
mois de juin 2002 donc laissé tomber
perdez pas votre temps à téléphoner à
les faire l'accueil bien alors d'abord
vous êtes dans mortel transfert
vous êtes battus par qui alors pendant
mystère il ya une mode sm en ce moment
là j'ai visé dans un magazine cette
semaine que ouais tu es abonné à
déstructurer ce marché dans max est pas
un magazine tellement d'heures grondin
cédant max il ya un club à new york où
on peut les faire fouetter à l'heure du
déjeuner oui c'est vrai il ya tentative
ayant travaillé sur fouetter
bon alors votre deuxième promo ses
orgies en noir qui était un film écrit
et réalisé par vous et produit par marc
dorcel on va en parler aussi répété
l'extrême
apa après et la troisième chose c'est
donc la sortie au printemps aux éditions
favre d'un extrait qui s'appelle les
femmes et la pornographie
voilà ces titres très provisoire avoir
beaucoup
attention aux visites vous êtes né en
1981 c'est bon la date
oui bien en fait votre nom est tiré d'un
personnage de bd c'est ça oui ovidie la
sanguinaire tu ne rates une petite rate
ensuite une bd de petits luxes et il a
tout petit luke en plus comme par hasard
bien dans l'enfance vous avez fait
beaucoup de danse classique
j'ai fait la danse classique du modern
jazz la danse africaine et de la danse
orientale
vous dites je compare souvent le porno à
la danse évidemment le porno c'est la
danse déstructurée mais de la danse
quand même il ya la même recherche de
performance corporelle c'est de
l'expression corporelle moi j'appelle ça
de la performance artistique
j'ai fait des performances artistiques à
côté c'est vrai que je le vis à peu près
pareil
psychologiquement vous êtes obligé de
renoncer la danse oui j'ai un problème
douce eau piégée à l'antigel méchant qui
fait que je ne peux plus dense et bien
alors à 13 ans vous décidez de plus
manger de viande
oui vous devenez végétalienne ce qui
n'est pas végétarienne dans moi j'ai eu
un fils mais manger
non alors végétalienne c'est pire que
végétarien pas ce que vous mangez au
pire
ah ouais à dire c'est mieux en mieux si
vous voulez pas de viande pas de poisson
pas donné pas d'oeuf puisque reste grâce
tout le reste
tout ce qui est pas nue mal les céréales
légumes et fruits dérivés s'écroulant il
faut des citoyens dans le sport
et des yeux cachés derrière les patrons
toujours n'est pas de sens les patrons
n'ont aucune drogue n'ont même pas de
cigarettes même pas d'alcool rien non
vous êtes street
oui et comment on se sent chez total
contrôle sur tout mon corps et je me
sens vraiment bien comme ça c'est vrai
qu'on a des boules de méthode qui pousse
jeudi sait pas c'est que par ce traité
les chiens trucs existent aux états unis
et les gens qui sont stratège aux états
unis vous n'êtes pas parler de ça
pendant le tournage non mais on sait pas
vu un seul
elles étaient des doses non pas par les
états unis elle a quand même pas des
relations sexuelles dans cette dans ce
truc
mais là bon d'après moi c'est ça vire un
peu aux religieux il ya des gens qui
sont 80 de ses actes au bout d'un moment
ouais mais bon ça va moi je fais que ce
qui me met pas nous y est ce qui me rend
bien donc les relations sexuelles ne
sont pas prohibés heureusement dans
votre métier mais dites moi alors
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui vous reste
non mais sérieusement si vous fumez pas
vous buvez pas au sexe ah bah ouais
bonne réponse
j'aurais anglade alors à 16 ans vont
quitter vos parents vous allez à tour
avec le petit ami de l'époque bac un
punk arista un pain cuit bac littéraire
latin avec mention et vous découvrez à
ce moment là la pornographie à vous
louer des cassettes plusieurs films x
par semaine pourquoi ce vous ennuyer
avec votre petit copain là le pari
surtout non je sais pas un jour j'allais
jouer mes cassettes vidéo
vidéo club juste en bas de chez moi et
je me suis dit tiens si j'allais faire
un petit tour dans le petit recoin tout
cacher et j'y suis allé j'ai vu des
jolie jaquette avec des jolies filles je
dis tiens donc j'ai regardé et là j'ai
vu des superbes américaine et là je me
suis dit c'est extraordinaire je veux
faire ça quand je serai plus grande
c'était une vocation quoi servent les
tournages quand même laissé un vrai
travail mais n'empêche rien que ça
vachement bien beaucoup mieux que
d'autres
imaginez être à 4 heures du matin avec
25 cm à 10 cm dans le bas ventre avec un
rhume et caetera et que vous avez vus à
faire croire à la caméra vous avez
énormément de plaisir moi j'estime que
c'est la comédie vous commencé à militer
dans les groupes d'extrême gauche à
cette époque la gauche libertaire mais
elles n'ont même pas la fédération
anarchiste parce que vous trouvez qu'ils
sont trop sauce dentro
sociaux-démocrates 6 anarchiste
qu'est-ce que ça devait être vous étiez
dans le coin à l'époque j'étais au
réseau no pasaran le sous commandant
marcos et tout ça quoi
oui enfin disons qu'on soutenait le
peuple du chiapas soutenait beaucoup de
gens comme ça mais je les ai quittés
parce que je trouvais que leur quotidien
ne correspondait pas du tout à leur
discours mais vous êtes rendu compte en
fait que même les anarchistes étaient
choqués par vous et par votre façon
d'être et notre façon de nous habiller
quoi donc j'étais patient narjiss que ça
finalement vous êtes rendu compte
c'est vrai que à l'époque moi j'aimais
bien m'habiller j'ai même bien maquillée
j'aimais bien portée des jolies sous
vêtements mes camarades portée des
treillis
des sweat shirt à capuche certaines se
raser le crâne et moi c'était pas du
tout montré vraiment pas et puis bon je
trouve ça un peu facile de dire qu'on
est anti sexistes et qu'on met des
taloches à sanaa n'a quant à elle a pas
fait la bouffe ou quand elle regarde
quelqu'un d'autre et vous êtes féministe
procès que sur ça veut dire quoi
moi je suis pour le fait que les femmes
s'assume en tant que femme et pas en
tant que images ou imitation de l'homme
je suis pour que les femmes
s'épanouissent sexuellement donc je
pense que quelqu'un qui n'est pas
évanouie sexuellement ne peut pas se
sentir bien et donc le 17 décembre 2012
est allé à l'assemblée nationale voir le
conseil national des verts c'est à dire
que vous êtes une militante politique en
fait oui je ne fais pas du tout parti
des verts mais j'ai été invité par les
verts pour intervenir sur la
prostitution et moi j'ai je suis
intervenu sur la marchandisation du
corps parce qu'il y avait un texte
contre la prostitution qui s'appelait
mon corps n'est pas une marchandise ou
je sais pas quoi
et moi j ai expliqué en quoi je trouvais
que l'argumentation de la
marchandisation du corps était une
argumentation très phallocrate finale
oui oui parce que vous dites y'a pas de
raison que la marchandisation du corps
s'applique qu'aux activités sexuelles en
fait on peut le mec qui bosse en usine
c'est la marchandisation du corps aussi
d'une certaine il ya de ça et puis ce
que j'ai expliqué c'est que d'après moi
le fait de dire une femme vend son corps
quand elle a une activité sexuelle
ça revient un petit peu à cette idée de
du don de soi et du pénétrant qui domine
le pénétrer etc
et je trouve ça un peu limite quant aux
féministes
ami jean-luc votre idée en fait c'est de
convaincre les femmes que la
pornographie peut être saine et ludique
et c'est rigolo non elles ne sont pas
toutes persuadé non mais je pense aussi
que c'est parce qu'il ya une grande
partie de la pornographie qui effraie
les femmes tout simplement il ya une
autre partie de la pornographie qui est
très machiste on voit des filles qui
font la tronche qui seront démontés ça
donne pas envie moi même
moi j'ai envie d'apporter une
pornographie et plus elles ou la nana
elle regarde le film et qu'elle se sente
déculpabiliser on vous en pensez quoi
vous non mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord et j'ai déjà commencé
elle était de maintenant mais je veux
dire je veux dire que je regarde ça
m'arrive assez régulièrement regarder
des films pornographiques avec ma copine
d'ailleurs et les choses se passent très
bien bien sûr et voilà alors vous êtes
dans le film de beineix donc mortel
transfert on la dit quand vous avez
rencontré des mecs si vous a demandé
jeudi pourquoi tu fais pas du vrai
cinéma ça vous a énervé vous faire du
vrai cinéma
oui je fais du cinéma pornographique
c'est on peut dire c'est le cinéma du
pauvre mais c'est du vrai cinéma c'est
un genre qui vous plaît oui énormément
bien alors au rejet en noir si le bo de
films que vous avez écrit réalisé celui
là produit par marc dorcel pour les 20
ans de sa société de production
alors c'est quoi l'histoire c'est une
histoire comme on en voit dans
neuf films z sur dix c'est à dire c'est
un jeune couple bourré qui arrive dans
un cimetière qui meurent parce qu'ils se
prennent la foudre et ils se font
attraper par des zombies
les zombies les amène devant la reine
des morts et appelé qui est moi et après
il l'air dans le cimetière en essayant
de trouver la sortie désespérément voilà
et la reine est mort elle est punie de
la sacrilège
on veut gagner tous ces jeux
[Musique]
j'ai alors 2010 alors donc des vêtements
mais vite c'est un mélange de film x et
de série z vous dites j'aime tout ce qui
est un peu mauvais cinéma terre les
perses qui apparaissent dans le champ
d'un manteau c'est normal la lumière on
peut pas faire un film parfait en cinq
jours 5
c'est impossible vous voulez faire un
cinéma porno égalitaire vous dites oui
j'ai envie de montrer un cinéma porno où
sont les femmes pas forcément plus
prioritaire pour les hommes et les
femmes les hommes et les femmes prennent
du plaisir ensemble ou séparément à
penser qu'on peut faire du porno
hétérosexuels non sexiste sur le fait de
faire l'amour devant une caméra c'est
pas sexiste en soit c'est difficile de
faire un film qui plaisent aux fans sans
que ce soit un film lesbien non je me
suis posé la question plein de fois est
ce qu'on peut faire un film
hétérosexuels non sexiste
mais je pense que oui c'est possible là
je suis en train de travailler sur mon
deuxième film et j'ai beaucoup plus
penser les scènes de sexe et je pense
que je vais montrer des scènes de sexe
très différentes et très intense
hétérosexuels vous dites c'est pas
génétique que les femmes puissent pas
être excité par la pornographie c'est
seulement d'ordre culturel il ya combien
de films x qui nous ont excité vous qui
m'ont excité vraiment je dirais qu'il y
en a eu trois ou quatre mêmes sommes sur
plusieurs centres pratique là parce que
s'ils arrivent à vous disais que j'étais
vous je crois que ça va se vendre
c'était des films américains s'appellent
touchez pas au grisbi briseur de cul
franchement des fois c'est le rendez
vous sur le plan personnel vous
préfèrent les femmes
oui parfois commun et pourquoi pas si
vous avez commencé comme ça où j'ai
commencé comme ça ma première relation
sexuelle était avec une femme je préfère
les femmes ça et vous êtes mariée et je
suis mariée avec un homme
non mais on ne décide pas de qui on
tombe amoureux tombée amoureuse de lui
c'est un accident mais bon je suis
mariée avec lui depuis bientôt deux ans
et se passe bien quand ça se passe bien
mais c'est vrai que à la base j'ai quand
même une préférence pour les vous aimez
pas alors il ya des filles qui aiment
les femmes qui aiment les femmes qui
ressemblent à des hommes vous séparez
vous aimez les femmes vous aimez les
belles gonzesses et des gros seins et
c'est ça c'est vraiment les femmes comme
un homme aime les femmes 60 ans alors
vous êtes très exigeante sur vos
tournages vous exigez un préservatif
vous dit en parlant des actrices de x
elle taille des pipes elles se font
limay pendant des heures pour un tarif
ridicule s'en fiche de paie avec des
horaires de l'enfer et sans protection
le fond mais pas toutes heureusement
mais il y en a qui qui subissent away et
moi non john ça vous coûte des tournages
et des gens qui vous considèrent qu est
ce que ça bien sûr parce qu on est très
peu en europe 1 ne tourner qu'avec
préservatif
ouais tout petit tout petit et en plus à
avoir plein de conditions sur les
pratiques vous refusez on peut le dire
elle faisait la malle avec sommes pas
bons mais j'accepte avec femmes à ce
seul prix que ce soit avec accessoires
est ce que quand on fait des faits de la
scion sur un plateau on peut en même
temps accumulé des points retraite
mais ça a l'air stipule que question et
c'est une vraie question c'est surtout
l'avantagé en fait c'est une question
d'actualité cette semaine est ce qu'une
couverture sociale à ces mots là c'est
sûr je suis intermittente du spectacle
à chaque fois il y en a qui hésitent à
se lancer dans cette corporation en
disant oui je n'achète pas l'avenir il
ya des points retraite
oui oui donc vous refusez l'anal vous
refusez lesjak faciale c'est normal
pourquoi c'est une question de
protection quand on demande à tourner
avec préservatif et qu'on se prend du
sperme dans l'oeil
ça sert à rien vous avez vous savez qui
est dans les films pendant que ça se
fait ça parce que je vois qu'on repense
à mon avis c'est bien pour ça que même
moi en tant que réalisatrice par exemple
j'en ai pas bien sûr ça s'appelle orgie
en noir
non
alors vous savez ovidie qu'on ne bouge
pas parmi eux jean galle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien leur en faire une interview
bendaoud dans votre métier vous avez des
hauts des bas on va faire italien penda
ce que vous préférez en vous encourage
ce que vous haïssez chez vous mon
orgueil ce que vous préférez dans le
cinéma et kung fu comédie à ce que vous
détestez les films violents et la mort
représentait dans le film où vous jouez
vous préférez un film qui s'appelle max
où je joue une petite arène et où j'en
vois férocement un boulet à macho celui
vous détestez je le sais moi
grax est bon la fête à jj non je n'aime
pas la faute à jj parce que c'est mon
premier film que c'était pas moi c'était
pas encore ovidie sinon le film qui m'a
vraiment le plus perturbé os x y z
pourquoi je regarde pas forcément un bon
souvenir j'ai trop donné de ma personne
ouais faut consciencieusement les plus
grands moments de votre vie
mon mariage le pire
je réponds non c'est pas maintenant moi
non non non bon la mort d'un proche
ouais ce qui vous plaît le plus dans la
vie
aucune la désagréable ce que vous
détestez
encore une fois la violence j'ai une
peur panique de la violence votre plus
gros coup de fric
ces derniers temps il ya eu plusieurs
coups de frais que ces derniers temps
beaucoup de fake beaucoup non voilà ce
que je fais pas un métier on gagne d'un
coup votre plus grosse perte de fric bon
mariage singh avait payé non j'ai eu
beaucoup d aide de la part de ma famille
mais c'est vrai que on ya laissé des
plumes mais je fais comment ce mariage
là parce que c'est le plus beau moment
de votre vie c'est ce qui nous a coûté
le plus cher donc on aimerait quand même
savoir
c'était un grand mariage végétales y en
a je sais pas la bouffe qui faisait des
crises et des légumes et les pattes
non c'était un très bon repas
avec tous mes amis et tous les amis de
mon marié toute la famille c'était cool
ce qui vous fait le plus rire en avi les
petites bêtes les hautes cimes souscrire
à ce que puisse rire ouais je reviendrai
sur le cinéma tout ce qui est finie la
découpe comédie ouais ça fait vraiment
poêlé et je vous fais le moins rien dans
votre vie la violence non mais c'est
vrai j'aime revenir là-dessus mais je
suis extrêmement parano et j'ai
extrêmement peur aux plus belles
histoires d'amour c'est avec votre mari
alors incontestablement est la plus
minable avec avec qui vous est arrivé à
tours la whey je dirais que j'ai un peu
stagné pendant deux ans avec un pc avec
ce oui j'ai un peu stagné c'était
quelqu'un de très très bien mais ça m'a
pas fait beaucoup avancer si vous avez
le plus sexy en vous tatouages bonjour à
toi les housses tatouage dans le dos à
la la ça fait deux ans de tête à et ce
soir c'est l'état tout est un mordu
est-ce que vous avez deux mois un sexy
j'aime pas mon ventre qu'est ce qu'ils
avaient de vente
c'est pas beau un bond à la fin
ce que vous préférez dans le sexe et
femmes avec des gros seins et non
vraiment vraiment étonnant si vous
détestez dans le sexe les machos voilà
français
tanger au noir
via
belinda vous êtes là je suis là bonjour
bonsoir thiery melinda c'est traductrice
hélas
fait quoi après l'émission en melinda
qu'est ce que je fais après l'émission
je prends mon jet je vais à caracas
et la belle beille là parce que en fait
je prends le rer pour poissy alors
ajouté
c'est à peu près ça oui melinda et là
parce que ce soir
anastacia
c'est un bon soir alors vous savez c'est
très facile de vous présenter on fait ça
est important
mais voilà
[Musique]
alors on vous appelle j'aime bien la
chanson de belinda est là
belinda c'est à kamsar on vous appelle à
eric becker folle c'est l'europe
c'est l'obscurité pékin folle de tout
petit j'ai commencé alors on vous
appelle anastacia la jeune tina turner
blanche ce qu'on m'appelle on m'appelle
effectivement tunnel avait alors publié
alors c'est comment on fait un lieu non
être le wild au rire
we dance in the date des caf all one two
three ont démontré qu'en mai regarde les
nippes chiboub est partout c'est à bercy
l album est générale il ya le single qui
extrait de l'album et qui porte le même
titre que l'album et qui s'appelle notre
cas
bien alors c'est un carton exceptionnel
ça marche ça marche énorme en france 2
n'est vendu à un million d'exemplaires
dans le monde entier hors match combien
vous avez vendu dans le monde entier
non tu te la frappe à l'espace 3
millions à les noms comme ça alors vous
dites la plupart de ses chansons ont été
composées rapidement et spontanément et
interpréter pareil parce que lorsque dur
belinda parce que lorsque je chante un
morceau trop longtemps au trot deux fois
il devient artificielle dire c'est que
c'est à partir du studio ces expériences
et par quand je suis sur scène je peux
le faire chanter un tube love tous les
jeux on met dans un studio
vous êtes en train de créer et si je
rencontre longtemps je me sens pas
naturel je me sens pas aussi vivante que
sur scène et je m'ennuie quand vous
devez être énervé ça doit être terrible
avec vous non je vous voilà vous êtes
sympa mais quand vous devez être énervé
un mauvais pas oui oui mais faut pas
faux pas mais normal a réagi tony l'a
fait c'est quand même parmi nos rangs il
est pas tellement là dedans les
surplombs sexuelle laurent est très peu
dense est vrai un very classique
je pensais que vous connaissez c'est
vachement son disque anastacia nombreux
bons c'est formidable j'étais très
surpris et en fait quand elle dit
qu'elle peut pas chanter trop trop de
fois en studio ça me fait penser à djoko
qui doit ainsi préféré chanter en live
et voilà et c'est peut-être le privilège
des grandes voix en fait alors elton
john
elton john il vous adore tout le monde
nous attend mais ce dungeon aussi alors
il vous a demandé de chanter avec lui au
madison square garden et après il a mis
un genou à terre et comme quoi il a pas
l'habitude elton john il vous embrasse
et le nombril c'est marrant il fait pas
bizarre parce que c'est pas le pauvre en
même temps que je me retrouve médusé
sans pouvoir parler c'est le seul homme
le seul qui puisse me garder silencieuse
est d'accord mais invisible avril donc
il m'a un petit peu chaud qui sur ce
coup
alors vous avez une voix bon c'est une
voix black mais vous n'êtes pas vous
n'êtes pas noir vous n'êtes pas beaucoup
de 200 noirs pas du tout même à oger
simplement d un petit slip taille mais
sinon vous êtes pas du tout de maggio la
fin de l'émission les strings je chante
vraiment du fond de mon coeur je chante
avec passion avec dallas me semble que
les gens veulent dire que c'est mais si
c'est vraiment la façon dont je chante
c'est tout à fait authentique c'est ce
qui me sort alors c'était difficile pour
vous parce que quand vous êtes arrivé
sur le marché les gens savaient pas dans
lequel catégorie vous placez parce que
avait une personnalité une voix très
étrange c'était dur pour moi parce que
je vous en voulez tellement et à chaque
fois que j'ai essayé d'avancer de
travailler avec quelqu'un il ne savait
même pas quoi faire avec une paire de
fois comme damian mon physique et et au
lieu de me laisser chanter comme je le
fais et c'est accepté par le public
ils ont décidé de ne rien faire ou alors
je vous savez j'ai fait des adjoints du
country différents types de musique pop
laden et l'attentât
ce champ parce qu'elle a surtout la
chanson bienbienbien belinda très bien
alors peut-être étiez noir dans une
autre vie je sais pas en tous les cas
vous appelez anastacia phone newkirk
vous l'avais un peu raccourci pendant la
guerre parce que c'est vrai que pendant
la guerre froide newkirk ça devait faire
avant le des faits vous avez été levée à
chicago votre père était chanteur dans
les boîtes
quelle boîte dans des boîtes il était
chanteur son père je vais te dis oui les
chanteuses et chanteurs dans des boîtes
de la côte est et dans des hôtels des
cats il est alors le père chantait donc
dans les 4 cl je chantais également
comédie musicale et je restais beaucoup
avec air dans les théâtres les coulisses
beaucoup plus qu'avec mon père dont je
requiers est parti voir quand vous étiez
jeune votre père est parti et à lester
bowie est encore parti toujours bas
revenus je sais pas si monsieur newkirk
nous regarde il peut toujours nous
téléphoner non retenu à chanter à
broadway dans la comédie musicale à
broadway
1 et vous allez en fait vous découvrez
bon vous allez dans une dans une école
dans une école pour pour apprendre mais
c'est surtout dans les boîtes à l'âge de
18 ans vous découvrez la house music 1
et c'est là que vous avez décidé de
devenir chanteuse mans voilà sur la
chaîne ntv il y avait un show comme ça
qu'ils s'appellent mtv club et il y est
alors il ya des filles des gogo girls
comme ça qu'ils dansaient vous étiez là
de nouveau et là vous avez rencontré
celle qui devenu votre votre agent on
peut dire lisa bras audet qui vous avez
faire une espèce de graines de stars
s'appellent de ktm tv c'est comme ça
qu'on vous a découvert vous avez fait ce
concours nous arriver en finale n'est
pas gagné j'étais riz dans le final mais
tous les présidents des grands labels
vous on vous en appelez et michael
jackson parce que mike abary michael
jackson c'est la première fois qu'il
voyait quelqu'un comme lui c'est à dire
une blanche avec une voix de noire donc
celle là complètement
et vous appelez michael jackson cette
question il pense qu'ils m'ont il m'a
appelé juste comme ça en fait c'était
tout à fait prêts nous vous le savez à
quelle est la fiabilité
il a expliqué au cours de cet appel qui
pensaient qu'on a plus de talent en tant
que chanteuse et que j'étais un artiste
à l'échelle mondiale et que je fais ex a
abandonné quoi que ce soit même si je
l'aï refusée par certaines misons donc
il était vraiment gentils avec moi ce
que je pensais de lui tout à fait gentil
l'avantagent avec michael jackson c'est
que ce n'était pas pour des raisons
sexuelle qui vous appelez en même temps
donc c'était ça qui était bien c'était
uniquement professionnel c'est davantage
mais il va donner son numéro de
téléphone ultra secret c'est vrai je
suis ici alors je suis content de vous
voir parce que vous j'avais lu avant de
vous rencontrer vous avez vous déclaré
souvent dans la presque physiquement
vous vous attirez pas vous aimez pas
tellement physiquement et quand on vous
voyait pas de raison de passer mais je
comprends pas ça c'est quoi cette
histoire
nastassia j'étais vraiment vous savez le
vilain petit canard
j'étais un peu comme la fin sans
mûrissant les choses se sont un peu
d'ambiance et j'ai vraiment des bons
maquilleurs et en plus vous avez un
associé à rencontrer son jules vous êtes
et standardiste à l'époque j'étais le
jour d'halloween et elles étaient grimés
en sorcière avec des couettes comme ça
énorme des dents noires des ongles
crochus
le mec vient dans le bureau il la voit
et je rappelle la wii est tombé amoureux
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire si vous avez
aimé dans cette situation-là et déguisés
comme ça après tout ce que vous voulez
alors vous êtes séparés et puis
maintenant vous êtes de nouveau ensemble
ça va il est revenue vers vous que c'est
lui qui est venu vous c'est vous c'était
tout à fait mutuelle
c'était notre karma notre test
j'imagine
iolo vous savez ils verront ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle il dit on bouge 3
pendant le kindle bonne réponse de
thierry ardisson bien on va faire une
interview croyance non maintenant je
peux bouger
est ce que vous croyez en vous oui oui
je prends pas ce que vous croyez en dieu
je crois en quelque chose de spirituel
un esprit in god we trust
est ce que vous croyez au diable oui je
crois au mal
est ce que vous voyez un elton john se
croyant superman non est ce que vous
croyez en jazz dubaï où bush n'ont pas
de commentaire pourquoi vous êtes en
france lorsque vous voulez là est ce que
vous croyez qu elvis presley est
vraiment mort même s'il est vivant
est ce que vous voyez au fantôme oui je
crois en ses fantômes qui en esprit et
l'esprit pour moi y est toujours mais
même quand vous a lieu dans notre grille
a dû rire ah bon est ce que vous croyez
au sexe sans amour
non non non non pas du tout oui j'ai
besoin d'aimer pour oui oui je préfère à
ce moment là mon passé ah oui vous
pouvez vous en passe de perdre du temps
combien de temps je suis à petit nombre
depuis longtemps
ça fait longtemps qu'on attendait
c'était oui c'est quoi il n'est pas avec
vous votre nom mais pas avec vous yahoo
à tanger par le pouvoir
ouais
la la la depuis combien de temps je vais
quitter les états unis
un ami à moi ça va être chaud ce sport
bien ce jeu vous fine ce soir est ce que
vous croyez à la masturbation est ce que
vous croyez à la régénération des
cellules de l'épiderme du visage par des
crèmes antirides loisirs que oui est ce
que vous croyez au père noël
non non il est dans ma loge est ce que
vous croyez à jean-hugues noël ces deux
importants contingents
d'abord je vais remercier belinda
à
et ensuite je vais vous laisser partir
parce que je sais que voilà vous
repartez tout seul en plus ce qui est
très vrai beaucoup de mérite
j'aimerais bien rester il faut vraiment
que je prenne un fort le manneken pis
toi des cantons ouais c'est bien sûr up
si vous ne saviez pas c'est quoi c'est
quoi comme tatouage bon les cadreurs
vous êtes prêts pour le tatouage bye bye
anastasia bye bye
[Musique]
voilà
jean mal de dos distance
[Musique]
bien jean hugues anglade donc ses vues
mais voilà au gie dit bonjour alors on a
un peu pâlotte ovidie parce que elle
mange pas de viande pas de poisson pas
d'oeuf pas de rien donc évidemment non
et j'ai de la famille pour l'eau n'est
ce pas parce que les polonais sont un
peu pâlot sent pas très bon mais ça
c'est vrai des polonais en même temps et
laurent baffie que vous connaissez gens
m'arrêtent je ne vous connais pas mais
formidable j'ai entendu parler de votre
travail
c'est bien vous jouez au gymnase en ce
moment oui j'aime bien ce we expect
lorsque la peine de réserver
c'est plein jusqu'en 2004 donc c'est pas
la peine d'aller faire la queue sous la
pluie non c'est pas en 2004 bien d'y
déguster un bon soir alors vous faites
un nouveau spectacle qui est mise en
scène et co écrit par jean marie bigard
voilà c'est une bonne idée à maladie
alors c'est comment on fait
marveaux c'est que même l'archevêque de
paris l'a fait quand même même le pape
chez lui quand il ay l'adn d'un des gens
qui
bien alors dix huit ans 100% gustave
censé ent % est à eynesse gens ne dit
rien des dix ans au palais des glaces et
pourquoi ce titre parce que moi je sais
pas mais moi je m'attaque la tête à tête
je dis rien non parce que didier gustin
joue le régisseur qui arrive donc sur
scène au début du spectacle et qui
annonce que évidemment gustin n'est pas
là et qui va faire patienter voilà est
donc en fait tout le spectacle vous
faites le régisseur qui fait patienter
oui c'est même c'est même beaucoup plus
riche que ça l'idée c'est que ça permet
aux régisseurs de didier donc le petit
jean claude ça lui permet de se ficher
dessus tout seul c'est à dire de dire si
encore ils avaient si encore il avait du
talent et pour arriver en retard et et
surtout c'est un spectacle ça c'est une
grande première qui explique qu'un
imitateur n'est rien sans les gens qui
limite ça c'est la première chose et ça
permet de faire au niveau de la mise en
scène de faire de faire jouer la porte
des morts la porte des vivants la porte
des comics et et didier ben il est si je
suis allé ce soir dans la salle avant
l'avenir à l'émission j'ai eu
l'impression de rentrer dans un bain
chaud tellement les gens étaient bien et
il ya la sortie m'ont dit bravo à moi si
j'ai rien fait c'est lui qui est gay
mais c'est vraiment un bonheur parce que
parce que il faut y aller ouais vous
faites à will survive avec la voix
d'yves montand et du bon temps ça fait
quoi
en fait il dans le spectacle qui
chantent très très bien l'anglais et il
envoie une musique bien vraiment voix
mais plutôt lui même plutôt deux
deriez à lui ça va y arriver
fried chicken wings au meeting
andy goode
philippe et la botte mal la poule ils
allouent fera à 8 jours
normalement
le spectacle on veut banny coup ces jeux
ces messieurs et mehdi son pénale dans
l'eau trempez là dedans mais il faudra
des cerveaux toucherait alors j'avais
deux moteurs et puis là
qui fait tranchant mais alors jamais
dans ma culotte
et puis d'abord fait profil bas
à l'épicerie yves gouttebel
je vais te mets ma force et ayew tout
mis
demain
je vais parfois amis et je veux courir
et vous
et
[Musique]
didier gustin
enfin il est bien
un spectacle
à jean marie bigard
messieurs après s'est passé comment avec
jean marie bigard ça va howe est super
bien c'était un peu moins grand bonheur
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses et voilà
pourquoi et pourquoi n'importe pourquoi
n'a pas bossé ensemble à l'arrêt fait
une belle paire vous n'avez pas trouvé
l'idée mais en tout cas je peux te dire
que la première fois la première mouture
à cannes et la reçut le prix du public à
cannes première première mouture et
qu'est-il arrivé à la fin on didier
gustin
moi j'en avais les larmes aux yeux il
s'est fait huer ce film déchirer les
gens s'y fait très bien alors marqué
c'est normal que vous soyez forts renvoi
parce que vous êtes né près de domrémy
sans jamais s'être jamais par thierry
ardisson alors gustin alors il ya un tri
changera pas avec vous votre père c'est
le cncf ce qui n'a rien d'étonnant dans
la presse nous dit qu il était sculpteur
sur bois parce que il a bossé il est il
a fait un peu plusieurs métiers il a
commencé par les cncf est pris on a géré
la rentrée dans un arbre dans l'est et
puis voilà et happy s'est dit tiens
pourquoi pas le bois et après vous avez
pas honte du fait qu'ils bossaient sncf
au nom non pourquoi vous dites toujours
sculpteur sur bois parce que je pense
que c'est le dernier métier qu'il exerça
à dakar et que l sncf s'était pas très
bien alors vous avez commencé à imiter
les autres à l'art en classe de sixième
ah ouais vous ai commencé avec georges
marchais et léon zitrone alors je dis
pour linda redick léon zitrone est mort
aussi comme georges marchais alors j'ai
commencé dans les vosges
1 les balles les mariages et où vous
avez vraiment commencé au ras du moyen
âge avec et là j'avais 17 ans
16 17 ans c'est votre frère comme l
orchestre mon frère jouait dans leurs
caisses
je faisais les lumières j'appuyais alors
j'avais tellement fière fière de faire
quelque chose dans le spectacle j'avais
deux boutons il ya un bouton home of the
hold up
à la fin je disais aux gens c'est moi
qui fais la lumière
je peux pas faire le sont ici non non
quand on cherche quelqu'un vient à l'âge
de 18 ans vous venez à paris ouais vous
commencez à 21 heures au théâtre du
tourtour et puis alors voilà ce qui fait
notre succès au départ parce que vous
avez repéré cvo association comics et
vous fait renouer avec la voix d'hugues
lysias tino rossi avec la voix de serge
gainsbourg
et puis voilà quoi nous ai trouvés
rapidement une grande cause c'est à dire
que bigard avait fait ce fameux sketch
que j'adore et dont je parle sûr que je
le vois sur les grandes causes
vous vous êtes trouvé tout de suite une
grande cause c'était les tortues tortue
avec bougrain dubourg j'ai défendu les
tortues à gonfaron ouhlala quand
michelin voulait construire sa vie sa
piste d'essai à gonfaron dans le massif
des maures
vous êtes allés défendre les tortues et
c'est comme ça que vous avez du sud
comment il s'est certes vous avez connu
mais je sais vous dire pourquoi parce
que j'ai connu alain bougrain dubourg
vous êtes un couple très uni avec 20
points ouais on c'est bon c'est on sait
bien depuis ça fait longtemps l'ap une
lettre qu un coup de fil pas mort non
non je pense
doit on faire un truc très dur
maintenant à faire un truc très dur
c'est lardy view mais vous allez
répondre avec une voix différente à
chaque question je suis obligé à chaque
fois ouais et a dit on nous croit
pendant le single bonne réponse de
tyrihans du scion vous pensez à quoi là
quand on sort de scène on a encore tous
ces gens qui vous applaudissent que
british adultes devant vous c'est femme
lui qui viennent devant vous offrir des
fleurs qui vous regardent comme ça c'est
le bonheur c'est ça ça ne vous dit pas
le matin quand vous voyez dans le miroir
non non non non tu veux dit je suis
moche mais mais mais c'est pas grave
parce que dans dix ans cette gueule je
regretterais
avenir semblait que dans le très petit
où est ce steve austin
lorsque je faisais je m'amusais quand je
venais de voir un film de steve austin
ma mère me dit tu vas y est ce que tu
vas le chercher durée oqali moi je
prenais je prenais les 400 francs et je
courrai et je faisais la bande-son
septembre tout en tentant de fuir leur
[Applaudissements]
vous écrivez quoi quand on vous demande
des autographes
allez vous faire [ __ ] tirèrent disent
on vous feriez quoi sinon rester 24
heures à vivre 24 heures je regarderai
les cassettes que j'ai pas eu le temps
de regarder bien la dernière chose que
vous faites avant de vous coucher
dernière chose que je fais je vais me
coucher je fais une petite briet 17
marie vierge marie s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît fait du chirac soit pas réélu
quelle est la phrase que vous ne
supportez pas d'entendre sept mois des
imitations
à chaque question
[Applaudissements]
avez vous pleuré pour la dernière fois à
j'ai pleuré ya pas très longtemps mais à
chaudes larmes
un film magnifique
ce petit enfant qui apprend à danser
billy elliot voilà c'est à ce film là
que j'ai pleuré pour la dernière fois et
celle d'avant c'était la vie est belle
avec be nice
bravo la dernière personne que vous ayez
eu envie de tuer tuer qui j'aime tout le
monde je tue et personne j'aime tout le
monde je vous aime
c'était
mais c'est mon avis
le surnom qu'on vous donne que vous
haïssez ses imitateurs l'époque hong
kong 10 contre ate d'imitateur gbot
j'aime bien répondu à la question je
suis d'accord j'ai remis les gaz
dans mon spectacle
par monsieur
c'est un peu moins et tout le monde vous
avez lavaud tournait avec 5000 personnes
par salle votre site internet et vous
faites en plus de bosses et du sein oui
je me suis chargé un peu la mule c'est
vrai mais
j'essaye d'amener tout ça de fond c'est
super agréable puisque tout fonctionne
ouais on va y aller un terrain comme ça
à mardi sont allés battre
maintenant on va parler de bigard
maintenant attention là jean marie mais
aujourd'hui si le site internet
ah oui bah oui www.bing.com foulée
biggar not' l'ebit garneau ça marche du
feu de dieu
ouais c'est vraiment drôle parce que je
m'aperçois qu'il ya des gens qui
m'aident beaucoup de fric dans des dans
des sites mais qui sont en fait des
nommés kiné qui sont des concepts et moi
je suis pas un concept je suis une
personne et donc les gens m'appellent je
reçois et je reçois une centaine de
mails par jour qui gêne j'ai une cyber
assistante qui a ri qui répondent à ces
super drôle parce que on lui demande des
tas de trucs même sexuellement
comment je suis et où elle est censée
être vraiment ma elle répond un petit
peu ma place et tout est donc il ya la
vérité elle dit pas mal la vérité way
sexuellement des conseils à des jeux il
ya une boutique
oui ma chérie moi je vous dis qu'est une
photo-montage chaque jour avec une
petite phrase donc chaque jour je suis
en avant de quoi louis 14 ans hugo en
pape en a il ya une petite phrase qui
qui accompagne donc voile bendit ou ce
pas il est beau monsieur poulat il est
pas mal le mot chapeau car mon conseil
d'aujourd'hui les filles c'est un
conseil sexuelle si jamais
vous nous astiquer le menhir on voudrait
vous demandez un truc nous les hommes
voudrais vous dire dès que le premier
gène pas calmos
arrêtez de tirer sur le bazar avec
machin passé nous après le premier jet
on commence à être terriblement qu'elle
mais voilà un bref laisser partir le le
truc tranquillement mais l'idée de
continuer comme ça a expliqué le bordel
parce que ça nous fait pas plaisir
d'acord c'est un truc qu'on veut vous
demandé depuis longtemps un les femmes
calmos après le premier jet voilà ça
c'est notre conseil d'aujourd'hui hockey
masculin avait les bras j'ai sur mon
conseil du jour tu as ta yo yo qu'est ce
que tu attends ton beau chapeau
questel de tes chapeaux d'état date de
chapeaute à des bouchons une semaine de
bouchons un mince et y passaient plus
mais bouchon tu passais plus alors
qu'ils pensent un tous les petits les
grands les vieux tout ça tout le monde
l'a fait petit bouchon olivettes pas à
la poubelle
on les met dans le petit carton et on
attend on va vous dire où les envoyer
vous dire comment devenir un bigarchons
dans votre département si vous avez un
local vous pouvez mettre au moins dix
tonnes de bouchons à semi remorques même
20 tonnes ça sera mieux et voilà il y en
échange tharoor rien que mon estime
bien sûr il estime que tous les gens que
ça va aider mes p'tits bouchons d'accord
s'allume qui bigarchons à demain alors
ça s'appelle un bouchon un sourire donc
tous les bouchons de boisson il faut
ramasser et alors ce qui est génial dans
cette association s'est déjà frais de
fonctionnement zero faim zéro centime
on demande absolument pas de pognon aux
gens leur demande juste de faire une
action d'amour quoi c'est à dire qu'il
peut être fait par les petits et les
grands
au lieu de jeter le bouchon à la
poubelle on le met dans un carton et
après on le donne
on a trouvé un mec qui rachète les
bouchons qui les recycle donc en plus
c'est écologique parce que le plastique
c'est dur 3000 ans et on va gagner du
pognon avec ça et on va pouvoir faire la
démonstration que ce qui manque c'est
pas le pognon c'est l'amour ouais
et que voit là sans rien demander au
lieu de jeter à la poubelle on met dans
le truc on ramasse les bouchons il me
faut encore d'aider bigarchons dans
chaque département il faut au moins
qu'il ya un mec qui a piqué un local et
puis dès qu'il a dix tonnes de bouchons
web a bien un camion qui arrivait il
embarque les bouchons on terminait et
effectivement il faut absolument rien
donner à qui que ce soit les gens aussi
ils ont envie de le faire ils le font si
l'on prend vie ouais eh ben ils le
feront alors je vais faire quoi du
pognon et le pognon va alors là on va le
redistribuer d'une manière un peu
forcément un petit peu arbitraire il ya
des tas de gens qui vont dire bah moi
j'ai besoin pour s'attribuer qu'on va
acheter des fauteuils parce qu'il ya une
association qui nous a aidés là dessus
les gosses les enfants dans les lycées
nous ont vachement aider à 150 lycée qui
se met à ramener des bouchons sur les
stades on est obligé de débouchés les
mais les bouchons parce que ça fait un
projectile fermé donc on récupère les
bouchons partout et tout le monde s'y
met et ses magnifiques parce que parce
que je peux dire aux gens maintien lors
cette semaine nous avait mis que deux
bouchons on sait pas énorme
sur le papier au niveau de la générosité
ça ferait pas grand chose mais peut-être
la semaine prochaine tu vas me donner un
peu plus avec les bleus
il alors vous êtes avec les [ __ ]
d'habitude c'est exemple à cette époque
de l'année la fête si non pas parce que
je me suis un peu reposé mais j'y suis
je fais là j'ai fait l'émission de télé
bien sûr et donc qui va selon va
l'enregistrer à lyon dans quelques jours
et elle sera diffusée à chypre pendant
un mois mois et demi et voilà vous
réagissez comme ans aux propos de
bernanke avait dit la semaine dernière
dans cette émission qui disait que
finalement les a foiré bon ça leur coûte
pas grand chose parce qu'ils se font
plaisir il chante sur une scène les gens
les applaudissent et on peut aussi se
donnent un air humain vous réagissez
comme bien sûr c'est plus que tout le
monde dise et ça c'est que de dire dès
que tu te mets dans le camp des gentils
qui essaye de faire quelque chose pour
une bonne cause il y aura toujours des
gens que je vais je ne donnerai pas
d'adjectifs mais il ya toujours des gens
qui vont dire oui alors on profite de se
mettre en avant pour dire moi je suis un
bon garçon puis je vais chanter
non je crois que que tous les gens qui
vont la bei qui chante et c'est jean
jacques goldman le grant est le candidat
du truc et il fédère surtout tout le
monde parce que tout le monde ne
pourrait pas faire venir 70 80 90
chanteurs parmi les plus grands chanter
je crois qu'en plus c'est une belle fête
et que tout le monde est très très
contents de voir des gens qui ne
viennent pas pour chanter leurs chansons
mais pourrait qu'ils viennent pas pour
vendre quoi que ce soit que que de
l'amour et donc c'est une entreprise de
toute façon formidable lavilliers ce qui
lie la charité c'est quand on n'arrive
pas à imposer la justice bien sûr mais
seulement si jamais on veut l'imposer
autrement on ne peut rien imposer sur la
lettre sur l'écrit sur la loi c'est
impossible
cc cessé depuis je crois que jésus jésus
l'a formidablement bien dit aux gens du
sanhédrin qui lui disais mais pourquoi
tu respecte pas la loi pourquoi est-ce
que tu tu sauves tu fais un miracle le
jour du shabbat
et jésus a dit kikis à raison celui qui
sauve le jour du shabbat je suis qui
laisse mourir
lequel d'entre vous ne va pas aller
rechercher une brebis égarée le jour de
shabbat
on va rester dans le sujet on va faire
une interview prise de tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien répondre brièvement sur des sujets
graves
c'est bien jean marie c'est bien le jeu
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles je
vous admire je sais que vous ne bougez
pas pendant le jingle et vous aussi des
biens êtes vous favorable à la sexualité
hors mariage bah oui parce que on est on
est pas à l'abri et puis des fois c'est
bien d'eux peut-être des fois de toucher
une autre peau une autre paire de
nichons notre choupinette notre under un
truc comme ça dont vous êtes vous êtes
favorable à la sexualité hors mariage
je suis favorable je jjg j7 je suis un
pauvre je suis un pauvre humeur
je pense que faut pas engueulé sans son
mari qu dans la veste y retrouve un
préservatif chaud ça nul de faire une
scène à son mari parce que trompé sa
femme avec un préservatif c'est une
petite bêtise trompé sa femme sans
préservatif c'est une grosse connerie et
donc je dis moi j'ai les couilles en
tout cas de dire bah moi que je pars en
tournée ma femme me prépare ma valise à
me mets mes chemises mes chaussettes
mais slip
puis elle me met une petite boîte de
préservatifs et beau temps je ne trompe
jamais ma femme mais c'est pour le cas
vous êtes favorable au divorce bas
je sais que ça peut arriver et si si
jamais c'est nécessaire bien sûr il faut
il faut le faire en ce qui me concerne
moi j'aime bien l'idée dans ma vie à moi
de mettre marié avec une femme et de ne
jamais la quitter jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours pour moi je trouve que c'est plus
du samouraï quoi c'est plus
bien est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'adoption d'enfants par dés couples
homosexuels lance pas la team a fait une
heure au téléphone
non non non oui mais non mais attends je
peux développer un petit peu parce que
maintenant il ya un truc est formidable
avec le pack si jamais tu dis par
exemple que tu es contre le pacs tu
passe pour un homme veuf
tout le monde fuit dans son froc on veut
pas être homophobe moi je suis pas me
fallut trouver peut-être que
l'homosexualité était plus sexy du temps
on était sulfureux c'était plus sexy
jean genet que les petits couples qui
vont faire les courses ensemble chez
auchan de matin non je dis simplement
que la république
n'importe quel gouvernement nous en tout
cas la république en général n'a pas
validé ce n'est pas le travail de la
république de valider une tendance
sexuelle ce n'est pas un troisième sexe
d'être homosexuel ça concerne d'ailleurs
à 80% les hommes déjà faut le dire c'est
pas un truc qui concerne les attaques et
simplement j'ai dit en déconnant à tous
mes copains homosexuel je le redis les
jours on n'en dormira un enfant tu sais
en lui disant et le brun charmant
embrassa le prince charmant
il ne se marièrent bas ils n'eurent pas
d'enfant puisqu'il se bourrer r le cul
par jour mais ils vécurent heureux ceci
dit je n'ai rien je n'ai rien du tout
vraiment encore une fois je le répète
parce que c'est hyper dangereux de
parler de ça parce que c'est la vieille
crainte dette de se retrouver au beau
flop non le trou de balle c'est une zone
érogène formidable et tout quand on ne
passe un peu le doigt sur le trop de
balles c'est génial ça peut même des
fois de sauver d'une demi mal donc moi
je suis pas du tout ennemi du dialogue
je voudrais bien mais ça c'est fait
alors qu'un tour qu'est ce qui arrive
aux autres je voulais la réaction de vie
dit ouais bah ça si vous êtes pour
l'adoption d'enfants par les couples
homosexuels
bien sûr et puis n'est-ce pas à la
république a décidé de quoi que ce soit
je dis on parle d'amour quand on parle
d'enfants à ma fille de la république ce
qui dit non mais attends vos amours et
des enfants on en a [ __ ] de république
la république l a pas défendre une
tendance aurait une tangente à un moment
je vais pas me poser la question de ce
que la république est d'accord à ce que
le bon dieu est d'accord à ce que est ce
que machin est d'accord on s'en fout de
la république si on les enfants au sens
où un enfant il deviendrait un train à
mon avis doit être élevée entre un homme
et une femme c'est quand même mieux pour
moi c'est là c'est la normalité
parce que je ne dis pas que de temps
aussi ça c'est anormal je dis que c'est
une originalité encore figure au cirque
pour être mieux s'accepte gamin il est
avec deux pas en compte comme les
valises et de mec
deux êtres fantastiques peut-être que là
dans ce cas précis ça peut être mieux
bien sûr je ne parle pas là on parle de
théories évidemment on est sur le sur le
papier sur le papier je dis que
l'épanouissement d'un enfants élevés par
deux hommes je pense que c'est moins
bien qu'un homme et une femme
j'ai le droit de penser ça comme bien
sûr bien alors jean marie en continu
l'interview prix choisi l'asie continue
l'avortement pour moi l'âme n'est pas
arrivé dans le foetus avant au moins six
mois et il n'y a pas une destruction
d'une personne 7-6 7/1 c'est un embryon
pour ceux qui pensent qu'ils ont détruit
une personne je pense pas que ce soit le
cas ça n'est pas suffisamment formés
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas
sortir un bébé du ventre de sa mère à
deux mois et le faire vivre parce qu'il
n'a pas d'existence encore l'euthanasie
l'euthanasie je suis contre parce que je
pense que il faut même si les
souffrances sont terribles je pense
qu'il faut les vivre jusqu'au bout et
que comme je crois pas au hasard encore
une fois je pense que il ya 10 à
différents cas de figure il ya télé jean
par exemple la technique peut permettre
de rester de laisser brancher quelqu'un
et de le faire vivre même contre ça veut
dire que naturellement il n'aurait pas
vécu et il serait mort donc après le
fait de débrancher quelqu'un qui a le
cerveau totalement mort c'est très c'est
différent mais je parle l'euthanasie
c'est à dire donner la mort c'est pas
retirer un médicament c'est différent
retirer un truc qui fait vivre c'est
différent de donner la mort mais donner
la mort non la peine de mort pour les
assassins enfants dès qu'on dit le mot
enfant tout le monde a envie de tuer
tout le monde
si on tue ton enfance où tes yeux la
peine de mort tu vas pas attendre que
les jurés délibèrent tu vas mathieu site
un pistolet dans la main tu vas tu tu
risques de la donner la mort
effectivement dans tous les cas de
figure je peux plus je pourrai jamais
dire que je cautionne la mort est encore
une fois comme le pacs quand c'est la
loi qui décide de dire voilà on va
prendre tel individu et on va le tuer
ouais c'est injouable
personne ne peut voter une loi comme ça
en revanche ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord
pour tout le monde mais une grosse
majorité des gens sont d'accord que
quand il ya des otages pris dans un
avion tu as des mecs du gign ils se font
avec une paire de couilles énorme comme
ça et qui on rend hommage d'ailleurs il
rentre il canarde et y tue les mecs et
tout le monde dit bravo
et là il n'ya pas de tribunaux ya rien
du tour décide de la peine de mort un
mec rentrer dans une école barre des
dynamiques comme anna lee roth on lui
met une balle un citron et moi
j'applaudis bas on a voté la peine de
mort on est tous d'accord à part
quelques trous du cul qui dit on aurait
peut-être pu le garder en vie mais moi
mais moi moi je dis non parce que moi je
dis que si un mec rentrent dans une
maternelle avec un paquet de dynamite
sur lui si ce mec risque la vie de
trente enfants qu'ils risquent au moins
sa vie et personne ne me contredira en
disant que depuis l'attaqué qui a été
fait sur l'avion il ya plus jamais de
détournement il y en avait il y en avait
1 tous les tous les six mois il y en a
pu parce que on se dit merde si je fais
ça c'est la mort sûre et certaine
donc je suis partagé entre les deux je
ne la donnerai pas je ne dirais pas
qu'il faut aller la donner mais en
revanche la loi c'est très très dur
parce que ce qui est écrit encore une
fois c'est exactement le thème de ce
qu'en disait tout à l'heure ce qui est
écrit n'est pas valable
il ya une loi pour chaque situation 4 le
mexique jeudi un mec qui piquent trois
pizzas entendu ça ipic si tu fais trois
délits d'un certain d'inde entre
certains états des états unis trois fois
le même délit perpétuité cds et un
sketch si je me mets avec le l'on fait
un sketch et dessus le mec qui piquent
trois pizzas y prend perpétuité il ya un
juge avec des mecs ils sont là le juge y
rentrer chez lui dit à sa femme chérie
j'ai fait mon travail aujourd'hui est un
mec qui l'avait piqué trois pizzas gmi
perpète
et tout le monde regarde dans le plus
grand pays du monde c'est à dire que ce
ilic ont le même souci pour une quiche
il échappe
il échappe à perpète il peut
jamais en plus si jamais si jamais ils
veulent les trois pizzas d'un coup elle
en congés les deux pour lui ça sera
pareil le préjudice est le même pour le
mec il va pas en prison
comment est-ce qu'on peut cautionner les
lois comme ça c'est la loi du coeur qui
fonctionne et c'est comme ça que
j'essaye de répondre à tes [ __ ] de
l'égalisation de l'année la légalisation
des drogues douces vous demande pas si
vous êtes talloires la légalisation des
drogues douces
oui oui oui bien sûr allons-y et la
libération de boris papon alors la
libération de maurice papon c'est à
mourir de rire
moi j'aimais bien badinter je laime plus
maintenant un bel intérêt nous dit au
pape on est les vieux et tout c'est pas
utile de laisser en prison dans les
ligues
crimes crimes contre l'humanité 1 ce mec
est un crime contre l'humanité il ya
crime il ya aussi l'humanité
ouais non mais oui d'accord mais
seulement ce mec on aurait préféré de
l'enfermer quand il était jeune on en
aurait trop fait on l'a eue que dieu et
on leur faire monsieur on leur ferme
vieux et malade et en plus
les saint servais et en plus je trouve
que c'est vachement sympa d'être en
prison vieux et malade ce qui était à
l'infirmerie tu gâches pathé vaise année
c'est mieux mais ça veut dire quoi de
libérer un mec ça veut dire que bon bah
c'est fini non non non c'est pas
possible il faut garder en prison à moi
je pense qu on le garde en prison il a
failli les juger il prend des années de
prison mexico à l'histoire que tu un
gars s'ils veulent un scooter on le
colle en le collant de saison quand un
mec il a il a tué une autre personne et
tout bas on le met en prison aussi et
puis si c'est un homme d'affaires qui
gruge des trucs et bat aussi est le fils
mitterrand comme madame mitterrand elle
dit j'ai payé la rançon la rançon moi
j'aurais demandé 15 millions 1 la rend
pas il n'y a pas de rançon le mec qu'on
lui reproche pas l'autre joué les gens
dans le vi mitterrand dire il me regarde
avec de la haine dans les yeux ils te
regardent comme il veut qu est ce que tu
en as à branler si t'as rien à te
reprocher il peut être regardée comme il
a bien sûr donc
et donc ce juge moi je le trouve je le
trouve génial j'ai je crois je le trouve
génial parce que même pierre botton j'ai
vu une interview et lui aussi je les
trouve formidable parce que les divas
comment il vous a enfermé vous êtes tout
prix et où il dit ouais mais oui du
compte je pense qu'il m'a remis sur les
sur les rails et n'a jamais attaqué par
quelque chose que c'est un enchaînement
formidable parce qu'on va recevoir la
femme de pierre botton voilà jean marie
bigard
alors jean marié va vous parler de
pierre botton c'est un enchaînement
formidable puisque nous accueillons
[Musique]
nous accueillons en zaïri noir
bonsoir anne valérie noir vous avez 35
ans vous êtes la fille aînée de michel
noir ancien ministre du commerce
extérieur ancien député maire de lyon
ancien représentant de la génération
moral et auteur de la célèbre formule il
vaut mieux perdre les élections que
perdre son âme au sujet des accords
droite extrême droite ce que feront
finalement billon a essayé de faire par
la suite lui il l'avait refusée le
problème de michel noir votre père on
n'est pas là pour l'accabler mais c'est
vrai qu'il a perdu non seulement les
élections mais aussi son âme et
apparemment quand on lit votre livre il
a perdu sa fille vous publié aujourd'hui
il vaut mieux perdre sa fille que les
élections c'est un livre qui est publié
chez flammarion
alors on va parler du bouquin on va
parler de la faire disons que le climax
l'apogée de la faire c'est le 17 février
1995 quand votre père produit pendant
son procès vos écrits intimes après que
votre mère les est soustrait pour
employer un terme sauf tu lui fais ça
pour échapper à la justice
et on va voir comment un père peut en
arriver là interview vérité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien une chose que je comprends pas
quand je reçois votre livre c'est
pourquoi ne pas avoir signé botton
puisque c'est toujours votre nom
aujourd'hui avoir signé noir
compte tenu des accusations que vous
portez dans ce livre contre votre père
parce que je pense que ce livre d'abord
c'est une histoire entre mon père et moi
tout simplement et
penser que ces deux forces avec noir non
mais c'est mon nom je crois que vous
êtes marié claire beau temps on appelait
boutons séparés je suis mariée et mon
mari oui et pourquoi aviez-vous aux
états unis écoutez quand on voit ce que
j'ai vécu ce que mes enfants ont vécu
il ya un moment il fallait dire stop
voilà et mes enfants souffraient
terriblement et moi aussi je vous ai
préféré tout coupé coupé les ponts et
les réflexions auprès des enfants à
l'école
elle était trop ça n'allait plus ouais
alors vous êtes aux états unis dont vous
êtes bookeuse dans une agence de
mannequins c'est ça travaille dans le
milieu de la mode
ouais et là vous êtes en france donc
pour la sortie de ce bouquin alors vous
êtes effectivement j'ai écrit ce livre
non pas pour régler des comptes mais
pour dire stop
mais en fait la sphère bouton l'a un peu
aux oubliettes en fait c'est vous qui la
remet tait la surface parce que il ya eu
la sortie du livre de pierre botton
qu'on a reçues ici d'ailleurs mais
disons que la faire aller enterrer la
pourquoi d'un seul coup vous savez c'est
vraiment je vous dis une fois encore une
fois c'est entre mon père et moi je
crois qu'il ya une il s'est passé des
événements il s'est passé que je suis
donc parti il ya 3 ans et l'année
dernière au mois de février
mon père a envoyé quelqu'un à l'école de
mes enfants
voilà et ça m'a beaucoup choqué par ce
contact avec vous oui enfin la personne
était ma soeur elle m'a dit je sais pas
peut-être une dizaine de fois c'est je
suis pas l'envoyer de papa donc voila
voila et si vous voulez c'est arrivé
après je me suis rendu compte que ça
arrivait à un moment qui pour lui était
crucial puisque après par la suite j'ai
appris que
il rentra en politique vous voulez c'est
grand a été cherché à renouer avec vous
pour finalement relancé sa carrière
politique pour pourra rendre pour
s'arranger
donc ça l'arrangé que effectivement il
est c'était une caution mais moi je ne
me servirai pas de caution bien alors ce
bouquin est très intéressant parce qu'on
voit finalement toute cette histoire
racontée par quelqu'un qui a été témoin
numéro un c'est le cas de le dire donc
au début on voit c'est peut-être ce
gears est où sa première campagne
électorale toute la famille s'y met pour
répondre au téléphone vous mettez des
tracts dans les enveloppes enfin tout ça
et ça c est assez joyeux et dès que
votre père était lui le regard des
autres sur vous changent effectivement
vous donner la fille du député vous
dites vous devenez un mini toit en
parlant de votre père donc on voit bien
déjà le la première rupture elle est là
c'est à dire que d'un seul coup on vous
regarde plus comme avant une rupture
vous savez à l'époque je crois que
c'était pas du tout perçue comme ça on
était très fier de ce qui se passait on
n'était pas du tout au contraire on
était très impliqué comme effectivement
je le raconte on faisait la chaîne
pendant cette enveloppe ensuite on
allait distribuer moi j'étais vraiment
une militante j'ai affiché pour lui j'ai
fait un coup de choses et c'est passé à
la rupture je crois que la rupture elle
est venue plus tard on va en parler
donc ensuite dont on voit l'arrivée de
pierre botton dans le cercle familial
première altercation violente avec votre
père quand vous lui annoncer votre
volonté d'arrêter vos études et d'entrer
dans la vie active et là effectivement
d'un coup le papa gentil devient assez
hard est une espèce de bousculades entre
vous
il vous dit tu vas continuer ses études
et si tu le fais pas je refuserais que
tu t'appelles plus longtemps noir bon
c'est vrai que d'un seul coup le mec
c'est un peu le masque qui vous a mis à
la porte vous a demandé de lui rendre
les clés de la maison alors en 86 vous
avez 21 ans
votre père devient ministre vous
commencé à fréquenter d'une façon un peu
plus assidus pierre botton avec qui vous
travaillez puisque effectivement vous
quittez l'école et vous quittez vos
études vous donne un boulot de
secrétariat auprès de lui et botton
pierre botton finira par vaux demandeurs
mariage des choses je comprends pas
poser des problèmes avec votre père dans
des
on sent bien que ça arrive et il est
toujours des problèmes et c'est normal
la fille aînée
on n'est pas les mecs son père c'est pas
trés c'est pas quelqu'un si vous voulez
chez nous il n'y avait pas de dialogue
et la discussion il n'y avait rien
c'était un père très autoritaire
apparemment oui trés trés tyrannique
mais je pense qu'il faut lui dire et
c'est vrai que vous racontez des
vacances à saint tropez où lui et joue
de violence elle et il fait régner un
ordre de faire parce que ça le dérange
oui non mais vous épousez quand même un
des plus proches collaborateurs de votre
père c'est à dire que malgré ce sont ces
problèmes qu'on sent arriver vous vous
épousez un proche collaborateur donc
effectivement ça pouvait arriver où
c'est arrivé non attendez je crois que
c'était totalement différent moi j'ai
épousé la personne que j'aimais et voilà
c'est tout c'est ça n'a aucun ça n'avait
rien à voir avec mon père c'était
totalement différent de nouveaux
problèmes surgissent lorsque vous vous
mariez effectivement avec pierre botton
c'est à dire que la cérémonie vous avez
l'impression qu'elle est transformée en
opération de relations publiques pour
lui complètement donc il se sert et
c'est tout ce que vous lui reprochez
finalement dans ce bouquin c'est de se
servir de tout le monde
il fait passer sa carrière politique
avant tout 1 et parallèlement ce que je
disais en commençant il tient un
discours sur la morale sur le fait qu'il
faut pas vendre son âme etc
il tient officiellement un discours très
très humanitaire est très voilà et puis
quand on voit la vie privée c'est tout à
fait différent en 88 votre père michel
noir perd son ministère
il n'a plus d'appartements de fonction
il va dans un appartement rue de
solferino qui est payé par pierre botton
et il dira plus tard au juge qu'en fait
c'est un appartement qui vous était
destiné et que vous n'aviez pas par un
caprice comme ça ça vous n'en vouliez
plus ça fait à mettre tout au long de
cette affaire il ya eu 1 1 des allers
retours entre lui et moi c'est à dire
que le juge faisait
trier entre ce que disait la fille ce
que disait le père parce
qu'effectivement mon père se rabattait
systématiquement sur moi il s'est servi
d'eux vous aussi pour sa défense on va
le voir
la même année les relations donc ses 80
des relations se dégradent entre michèle
noiret et pierre botton ne sache je
crois que ça c'est entre eux déjà c'est
pas c'est pas quelque chose que je peux
mais c'est vrai que je pense que mon
père est quelqu'un qui utilise les gens
complètement
c'est un vrai je dirais c'est un pur
politique voilà l'utiliser et après
quand il ne peut pas se regarder dans la
glace et dire j'y suis arrivé moi même
fait le ménage plus ou moins de plus ou
moins bien plus ou moins avec la classe
mais c'est quand même le mélange alors
bon finalement pierre botton fini par
quitter ses fonctions à l'hôtel de ville
de lyon
mais avant il demande à votre père de
lui signer une reconnaissance de dette
puisque des finances et toute son
expérience que la turquie ne sais pas du
tout ce qui s'est passé
bon c'est pas du tout je veux dire le la
reconnaissance de dette est ce qu on
appelle ce qu'on a appelé le protocole
est un document que moi j'ai vu arriver
chez moi à un moment où donc
pierre était parti et c'est quelque
chose que mon père a écrit et envoyé
comme ça et c'est pas du tout je veux
dire on n'oblige pas michel nord à
écrire quoi que ce soit et alors là bon
ce qu'on apprend dans ce bouquin c'est
que votre mari pierre botton vit une
aventure il vous cocufie 1
il vit une aventure avec la fille d'un
personnage important de la république
dont vous citer le nom dans votre
bouquin et là vous êtes désespéré
évidemment où c'est tragique pour vous
et vous écrivez trois pages sur un
agenda trois pages qui seront produites
par votre père vous l'écrivez dans un
moment de déprime et c'est tout le coeur
de la faire c'est page que vous écrivez
dans un mode en ce moment comme ça
d'abandon seront produites par votre
père à la barre pour pour sa défense en
fait pour essayer de s'en tirer alors
votre mari il a des ennuis pierre botton
il se retrouve en prison en garde à vue
à puis après en prison vous appelez
votre père pour lui dire à caen où tu
peux pas laisser pierre mon mari est un
ancien collaborateur en prison et vous
découvrez en fait qu'il n'a aucune envie
de le défendre il vous dit la police
possède des éléments très vague il a
fait des conneries donc excuse moi mais
plus personne ne peut rien pour lui
il vous demande même de vous séparer de
votre mari et je crois que mon père a eu
dans toute cette histoire une attitude
purement égoïste
il a essayé de si vous voulez me
récupérer effectivement à un moment qui
était qui était important pour lui
il a souhaité faire ce que je raconte il
a souhaité faire un noël en 1992 pour
les enfants parce que j'ai deux enfants
et donc il m'a demandé de venir et de
participer à noël
j'y suis allé et mon père a souhaité me
parler donc je l'aï vu et m'a demandé de
divorcer et donc je suis parti avec mes
enfants voient là et là donc j'ai
entendu pas mal à mon père
votre père michel noir on la commence à
accuser botton il dit en fait si j'ai eu
des relations avec lui
c'est uniquement parce qu'il était mon
gendre l'appartement de la rue de
solferino en fait il n'était pas pour
moi même si botton de payer 1000 été
pour ma fille donc pour vous à ce
moment-là botton remet au juge cette
fameuse reconnaissance de dette
et en fait en dix ans et c'est là le
coeur de la sphère il dit en fait je
n'ai signé ce papier que parce que
botton me menacer de quitter ma fille et
elle se serait alors suicidée
et pour prouver ses dires y produit et
c'est bien plus le l'objet de votre
bouquin il produit ses trois pages que
vous aviez écrit comme je le dis dans un
moment d'abattement en découvrant en
découvrant vous étiez cocu même le juge
ait choqué quand votre père sort c'est
sort ces années je crois que tout le
monde a été choqué c'est un acte qui est
inqualifiable ne fait pas ça si vous
voulez je pense que le rôle d'un père
c'est quand même de protéger ses enfants
mais pas des enfants au monde pour s'en
servir comme bouclier et je pense que
c'est ce que mon père hafez il a
sacrifié sa fille pour essayer de s'en
sortir alors qu'en face de lui il y
avait toutes les preuves et si vous
voulez jouer en plus dense et dans cette
histoire enfin je veux dire il y avait
il y avait trois pièces étaient de
lettres et et je veux dire il a il a lu
que ce qui l'arrangé
donc c'est un petit peu en fait le dos
au mur pour se défendre pour assurer sa
défense le dos au mur il finit par
produire ces lettres alors en plus ce
qui est horrible c'est que ces décès des
documents vous aviez confié à votre
grand père votre grand-père bon était
vieux était malade et un jour il vous
appelle et des coups tu devrais venir
récupérer tes papiers et vous découvrez
à ce moment là que votre propre mère
avait soustrait ses passes de l'agenda à
votre grand père dont elle les avait
évidemment il avait donné à votre père
pour qui les utilise dans son procès
alors un truc et bizarrement votre
bouquin c'est que vous semblez plus en
vouloir à votre père qu'à votre mère
parce que quand on lit le bouquin c'est
quand même votre mère qui est allé voler
ses lettres chez votre grand père ac
c'est ma mère qui est totalement appris
appris ces documents
mais si vous voulez ce que ce que je
vous savez entreprendre quelque chose et
avoir une utilisation tél il ya une
différence
jeudi ils pouvaient très bien les
prendre et puis pas les utiliser surtout
que c'était pas c'était quelque chose
qui avait été écrit un autre moment
oui vous étiez dans l'avion voilà un
fait qui n'est absolument pas été écrit
au moment où soi-disant il a été écrit
le protocole age 2 donc si vous voulez
alors au tribunal la production de ces
lettres vous vivez ça vous c'est normal
comme un coup de poignard dans ce
courrier sortir ces lettres vous aviez
confié à votre grand père vous les voyez
sortir en plein en plein prétoire
vous comprenez bien à ce moment là que
votre père vous sacrifier la politique
et vous prenez vous pour la décision de
porter plainte pour pour vol contre
à l'époque j'avais parlé bien tout à
fait vous savez j'ai ce jour là je crois
que le ciel m'est tombé sur la tête
ça marche ça a été l'horreur l'horreur
parce que je pensais pas que voulait il
était capable de faire beaucoup de
choses mais je pensais pas qu'il était
capable d'aller si loin
il ya des jouets du tchekhov après donc
c'est un mec très décidés à faire
n'importe quoi comme celui-ci je ne sais
pas il a déjà fait de la prison votre
clan ben ali a été acquitté de tous il a
été il a complété condamné à de la
prison avec sursis il a été condamné sur
touche pense que c'est la chose qui me
touche le plus à cinq ans
d'inéligibilité et il aimerait
financièrement une amende si eu une
petite amende
j'agis donc en fait rien quoi si ce
n'est l'inéligibilité pire que tout et
puis de toute façon je ne souhaite la
prison à personne justement justement
votre mari pierre botton veut en prison
elle un calvaire pour vous continue
parce que ce qui est terrible c'est
vraiment un calvaire c'est le cas de le
dire quand vous allez le voir en prison
il vous reproche des choses et vous vous
dit que vous êtes de mèche avec les
autres enfin c'est à dire il vous dit un
jour je n'ai plus confiance en toi
oui mais ça je crois que vous savez la
prison est quelque chose qui qui qui
détruit tout qui détruit tout repère qui
détruit absolument tout et vous re
accomplissent des autres oui qui va se
suicider il a fait une tentative alors
le vous qu'est ce que vous faites voir
celer tout le monde comme écouter c'est
normal comme lucie aubrac quand elle son
mari tante olga que vous vous essayez de
alors vous appelez tout bon toute la
journée vous découvrirez que la taule
c'est très dur pour des pour des gens
qui sont pas prêts à y aller quand même
c'est plus facile que tu vas tous les
quinze jours que tu t'habitues et tu
connais tout le monde et ouais mais que
t'es pas du tout habitués que tutu un
joli 30 vies c'est vrai que ça détruit
fort les gens ça c'est sûr alors vous
vous allez très loin parce que non
seulement voir celer bon les gens du rpr
extrême et vous allez voir chirac génie
les bains alors apprend vous le reproche
à bernard pons qui vous appelle non mais
qu'est ce que tu as fait qu'elle ait
dérangé le plus dans le public mais vous
vous êtes une femme vous êtes une femme
qui aime on comprend ça très bien non
non on puisse savez je crois quand
quelqu'un est capable en plein meeting
électoral devant un parterre de
plusieurs milliers de personnes
quand vous êtes enceinte de descendre de
l'estrade de vous emmener
à votre voiture de vous raccompagner
dans un moment où il a besoin de vous il
a déjà que chirac
si vous voulez moi j'étais tellement
désespérée que je me suis dit je vais je
vais aller le voir c'est mon dernier
espoir je suis fort on passe à autre
chose et si vous voulez je suis pas allé
le verra l'elysée non plus je suis allé
voir à un endroit qui était discret et
j'ai eu une fin de non recevoir
alors que quand c'était utile on me
raccompagnait on embrasse est devant
tout le monde et j'étais la petite
cocotte de tout le monde alors la bomba
vous partez aux états unis avec pierre
botton votre mari mais lui quand il
revient en france il nous l'a raconté
ici d'ailleurs quand il revient en
france non seulement il a plus le droit
de sortir de france mais en plus cela
plus droit de rentrer aux états unis
donc il est resté en france et vous vous
êtes là bas comme on l'a dit aujourd'hui
vous êtes pas divorcer mais c'est pareil
alors il ya une chose aussi en lisant
votre livre qui est étonnante si vous
semblez plus facilement pardonné à votre
votre mari qu'à votre père c'est pas une
histoire de pardonner cc je crois que ce
livre il est vraiment entre mon père et
moi c'est tout c'était vraiment pour
pour essayer de faire comprendre ce que
j'ai subi
je veux dire je suis tombé vraiment très
très bas âge et ça a été terrible pour
moi et j'essaye de remonter et si vous
voulez je voudrais vraiment mettre un
point d'arrêt tout cela c'est à dire je
ne laisserai pas recommencer à
m'utiliser c'est pour ça je ne laisserai
pas venir me chercher comme ça en
m'envoyant quelqu'un je veux dire
pendant des années mon adresse a
toujours été dans les procédures
mes enfants n'ont jamais reçus de cartes
pour noël n'ont jamais reçu de cadeau de
noël depuis 1992 parce que déjà quand
votre premier enfant né il vient à la
clinique et déjà vous ne trouvez pas
débordant d'amour pour pour l'enfant non
pour l'enfant oui c'est ça parce qu'ils
étaient même il n'était même pas capable
c'est en campagne électorale il avait ce
terme il appelait l'enfant quand il
parlait à quelqu'un parce que de peur de
se tromper de sexe et de prénom et je
veux dire il a appliqué à sa
petite-fille jusqu'en télé n'est alors
que c'était
c'était quand même est un moment de joie
pour tout le monde alors quand votre
père essaie de reprendre contact avec
vous donc par l'intermédiaire de votre
soeur vous pensez que c'est une
stratégie pour les législatives de 2002
parce qu'en 2002 michel noir va être de
nouveau éligible donc effectivement la
question se pose
et vous vous croyez pas vous croyez pas
qu'il puisse avoir lâché la politique
non parce que je crois que c'est
vraiment un homme politique est la seule
chose qu'il fait vibrer vibrer c'est la
politique je pense qu'il l'a il a montré
il l'a montré depuis en plus dans cette
affaire il a montré que c'était la
politique avant tout alors maintenant
vous avez fait ces livres pour sûr que
au cas où il devrait continuer ce
représenterez éventuellement c'est pour
bloquer sa carrière aussi où c'est beau
c'est bien je vais vous dire c'est
vraiment pour que la vérité soit écrite
noir sur blanc et qu'on puisse cuir vont
donc si jamais vous voulez continuer moi
la question je sais pas je me dis je me
dis la question que se posent les gens
qui ne regardent en ce moment est ce que
vous faites ça pour qu'ils continuent à
être inéligibles bien sûr la fin de ces
de sa vie donc est ce que c'est une
revanche qui ont un poids ou un boulet
mettra son pied ou est ce que c'est
juste pour mettre un terme comme vous le
disiez pour traître c'est pour mettre un
terme et si vous voulez ma carrière
aussi maintenant pour m
non c'est pour vraiment mesquin de terre
ont peut-être très certainement vous
savez tout a été lié dans cette affaire
donc
mais c'est vraiment pour pour que moi je
puisse recommencer ma vie c'est une
thérapie pour vous voilà ce que je veux
dire c'est ma thérapie c'est j'ai vu des
médecins j'ai je pense essayer
absolument tous les médicaments pour
essayer de me relever
j'ai deux enfants je veux pouvoir aller
de l'avant et si vous voulez moi je veux
par ce livre vraiment tourné la page et
montrer que je n'oublie pas parce que je
pense que oublier c'est accepter qu'il
recommence mais après ce bouquin dans un
coin de votre tête vous pensez qu'il ya
un espoir de réconciliation c'est
justement est ce qu'on peut vous
éteignez la lumière chez vous est ici
aussi
alors anne valérie noir la seule
question finalement que j'ai envie de
vous poser pour terminer ce soir
est-ce que vous pardonnerai jamais à
votre père est ce que vous envisagez à
un moment quand même le pardon ça existe
sur cette terre est-ce que vous pensez
que vous lui pardonnera je ne crois pas
il a gâché ma vie et j'en veux plus
voilà c'est tout
quand je dirais que je ne veux pas
pardonner ça ne peut être que passagers
parce que
faudra de toute façon égale
éternellement les comptes ne peuvent pas
ne pas être réglés est ce que je trouve
le plus terrible parce que il ya des
gens sur la terre qui sont des ordures
qui se comporte mal y en a plein mais
votre père pour être élu a quand même
raconté aux électeurs et aux français on
l'a entendu à l'époque nous dire vaut
mieux perdre les élections de son âme ça
s'appelait la génération au moral en
partie versé des gens c'est ce qui est
pire c'est comme crozemarie tiac
rosemary mois qu'il ait piqué le pognon
des gens du cancer sur le 16 juin
pardonnerai jamais a eu envie on se sent
merdeuse parce qu'on les a bien créé ce
qu'on les a crus et qu'on a raison bien
[ __ ] quoi vous êtes six enfants les
autres ils ont sans doute par rapport à
votre père et je n'ai jamais je n'ai pas
eu de contact depuis 1992 avec avec avec
tous vos frais
oui en dehors du fait que ma soeur soit
venu à l'école de mes enfants je lui ai
parlé au téléphone
c'est tout ce que j'ai eu et c'est vrai
que ça me manque je suis l'aîné de 6
quand même je suis le nez gelé je me
suis occupé mes parents ont été traités
souvent absent la troupe du jeu il me
manque il me mange connais pas mes
nièces c'est terrible pour moi qualité
donc faut mieux pas voir un père qui
fait de la politique j'ai absolument ce
qu'on peut que tirer comme quoi les gens
c'est déjà la veille deux hommes
politiques on connaît vraiment beaucoup
je connais beaucoup d'enfants d'hommes
politiques moi je suis vraiment un cas
extrême mais je connais beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont pas bien machiavel
disait cantonales pouvoir le seul truc
important c'est de le conserver à tout
prix ou galilée décrivait la réalité
pour beaucoup d'hommes politiques le
livre de chevet le prend bien le merci
beaucoup a d'ailleurs les noirs de votre
courage est venu témoigner
on va lui voilà il vaut mieux perdre sa
fille que les élections donc chez
flammarion âme de l'ailé noire merci
beaucoup je vous laisse partir parce que
je sais que pour vous c'est déjà un bel
effort d'être venu jusqu'ici
merci beaucoup et voilà ça pique les
élections c'est flammarion
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
bien et maintenant mesdames messieurs
j'accueille patrick chesnais
il
merci
et vous obtenez n'importe où en même
temps au vide et 13h c'est que les
couples se forment à la télévision vous
savez ça ah oui mathilde seigner laurent
gerra david l idée est l avis d benjamin
castaldi flavie flament patrick chesnais
ovidie ça ça a commencé sur un plateau
de télé et voilà mais elle est comme ça
veut dire comment il est il le dit lui
même a dit j interprète souvent des
personnage bourru mais avec du coeur des
personnages qui au début sont
rébarbatifs donc là vous fais un peu
rébarbatif mais qui au final emporte
l'adhésion du public et c'est vrai alors
vous avez fait beaucoup de théâtre après
effet du cinéma on vous a vu chez de
ville dans la lectrice avec mu mais
aussi chez lelouch et lautner chez
brigitte rouan avec post coïtum animal
triste
vous auriez aimé être footballeur mais
aussi musicien de jazz ou écrivain et
finalement vous allaitez comédien et
aujourd'hui vous êtes réalisateur
voilà un alors c'est comment on fait le
taux courants attention on est prêt au
vide et c'est bien tout le monde le fait
choisi alors à vue revient peu traîné la
maison abc vient pas très professionnel
alors ça nous casse les couilles à 220
aussi mais bon le premier film de
patrick chesnais comme réalisateur
s'appelle charmant garçon il est réalisé
par patrick chesnais avec patrick
chesnais alexandra vandernoot jean
françois balmer bernard crombey 1 et et
micheline presle du film des pétards si
je dois dire que si j'avais cru un jour
dans ma vie voire micheline presle fumer
des pétards
oui mais c'est ce qui l'a intéressé dans
ce film c'est ce qui vous intéresse il a
continué sa rien maintenant tu te rends
compte micheline presle qui fument des
pétards c'est incroyable c'est vrai t'as
vraiment de l'ecstasy des français
bien alors voulez que je fasse le pouce
je suis où je fais le pitch des gens que
j'aime bien je fais le pitch alors c'est
l'histoire d'octave qui est joué par
patrick chesnais il se balade avec deux
copains qui s'appelle achille et hector
qui sont donc balmer et crombez hill
zone la nuit dans des bars glauques dans
des épiceries buvette comme ça et octave
un jour sur un parking il voit arriver
une gonzesse dans un 4 4 une très très
belle gonzesse et qui s'appelle esther
et ils flashent complètement sur elle
mais un monde les sépare
1 elle elle est cultivée créative belle
elle a un ami qui est ministre de la
culture qui est homosexuel
lui au contraire ils et pleurnichard
passez-vous un pleurnichard grossier
violent et il tombe il tombe amoureux
oui il tombe amoureux la partie
s'annonce difficile et il s'accroche un
peu maladroitement mal quoi c'est à dire
que c'est il est pas que pleurnichard
elle est surtout violent bougon et
vulgaire ouais ben moi je ne s'agit ni
par marché ça finit par marcher on va
voir à quoi ça ressemble vous êtes bénis
tous ces jeux vous êtes mariés vous avez
des enfants
il ya beaucoup de femmes qui se
souviennent de vous tous à faire quoi
bolivar de filmsactu aller
[Musique]
les fans confusion c'est un peu ma vie
disons que souffert
sauvage et au prix kevin costner
la petite ville de merde t'as mal qu'on
peut vivre beaucoup d'énergie mais je
peux pas j'ai rencontré quelqu'un croit
que la ville vous est spécialement
réservé vous a privé pour rouler avoue
franck de boer aux initiales tdc ont du
tube [ __ ] passons de complètement son
type mais je peux changer s'il ne veut
pas subir quelque chose que j'ai pas
choisi tu comprends je trouve toi
maintenant j'ai mal aux pieds chiens
dangereux chauffard et une fête dans
deux têtes grossesse comme elle tord
envie d'un mec comme toi t'es mignon
c'est 3 non je ne crois pas bientôt tu
me tues moi bien sûr tu m'a toujours dit
tu vas t'éclater adéquat à souviens tu
étais sur le cocotier tâche des impôts
des taxes à la tâche en géo kara
n'imaginons pas de salle et nous parce
que là on va pas ce concert ensemble de
total et en tire bouchon
je tiens mes cheveux je gagne deux
points produits comment tu parles bord
des voitures
[Musique]
je vais très juste mais juge est une
énorme sensibilité chez les femmes
enlacées bon pied d'ailleurs on peut
dire que vous avez une presse excellente
et on en est ravi vraiment exceptionnel
je la presse est exceptionnel elisabeth
quin et mais oui ce qui était attendu et
c'est énorme
la première chose qui m'a impressionné
non mais c'est vrai la jamaïque et
depuis trente ans et que les diabétiques
un maître chien adoré le film on dit le
plus grand bien à tous les jours et puis
bon la presse voit l'appareil alors eh
oui la presse de des cahiers du cinéma à
vsd ou à poissy d'ailleurs vous a mis du
temps à le préparer ce film a quand même
la passe rien à voir ouais mais ça ne
suffit pas il ya 20 ans 30 ans parlait
déjà de ce film c'est vrai quand vous
accrocher à esther de l'autre côté super
maladroit vous êtes vous est craquant
quand vous êtes touchant c'est clair on
vous aime
oui j'ai ont même malgré tout voilà que
je suis avant tout un
qui vient de rébarbatif d'insupportable
très agaçant très antipathique
c'est ce que j'aime bien et puis malgré
tout sous le sous le fumier il ya des
roses qui pousse c'est ce que j'ai
toujours aimé faire au théâtre ou cinéma
c'est à dire essayer de 2 de rendre des
personnages un peu très antipathique
mais qui se découvre avoir une âme
moi je dois dire un choses hein je le
dis vous m'avez profondément ému dans
une pièce qui s'appelle skylight avec
zabou j'étais bouleversée par cette
pensée de pierre vous étiez voilà quoi
alors mais elle aussi esterle alexandra
vandernoot lac est riche et où québec un
4/4 elle s'attache s'attache à ce casse
couilles que vous incarnez souvent la
ligne droite c'est très séduisant c'est
à dire qu'il va droit au but ouais bon
ça peut être très insuffisant je connais
beaucoup de jeunes femmes autour de moi
qui sont ceux qui sont sensibles à ça
bien c'est dans un cinéma près de chez
vous
rien
bien voilà vous restez avec nous
j'accueille maintenant
[Musique]
l'abandon
yann moix
yann moix bonsoir vous oubliez votre
troisième livre le premier c'était
jubilation vers le ciel le deuxième
c'était les cimetières sont des champs
de fleurs et le troisième c'est alice à
corto il est sorti il ya quelques mois
ils étaient bien accueillis vous savez
comment on fait yann moix alice accord
très bien alors le pitch je le fais vous
le faites
allégis bien alors donc le narrateur je
fais court mais c'est un pitch le
narrateur sort d'une école de commerce
il est embauché à disneyland après un
concours de recrutement soit disant basé
sur la culture générale et il devient
donald le mec il devient donald à
disneyland avec le truc et tout lui qui
a lu proust eagle brecht einstein est
tous un peu dur pour lui se retrouve
donald et fait une tentative de suicide
et à ce moment là il est le seul recours
qui lui apparaît ça ne vous surprendra
pas jean marie bigard c'est l'amour il
décide d mais une jeune fille jeune
beurette qu'ils voient comme ça et qu'il
qu'ils traquent sans jamais osé
l'aborder
il la traque jusque dans son hlm et il
s'installe dans son appartement quand
elle déménage et vous dit yann moix
derrière le masque hilare de donald duck
pleurer un petit c les batteurs amoureux
d'une beurette en couple et voilà tout
est dit c'est la trame du livre quant à
la trame du livre est la seule issue
pour assouvir sa passion c'est le crime
et le canard tranche la carotide d'alice
à corto elle m'avait refusé des instants
elle m'accorderai l'éternité voilà
c'est bien
voilà le livre de yann moix et cruz la
marne la vallée voilà oui non c'est de
montrer effectivement que il ya des
métiers bizarre sur la terre comme par
exemple déguisée des êtres humains en
animaux et les mettre dans des parcs à
thèmes et c'est quand même assez absurde
que c'est la déshumanisation et total
dire qu'en plus il faut que les mecs se
taisent
c'est des mecs qui viennent des pays de
l'est en général qui ont fait la manche
dans le métro pendant des années et là
ils se sont tous retrouvés pour faire
donald dingo mickey alors c'est
fascinant parce qu'il ya des séances de
dédicaces plutôt dédicacera je sais pas
quoi une feuille de papier de 17 heures
à 18 heures au palais enchanté c'est
aussi con que donnait là des farines
animales à des animaux végétarien
exactement il ya un côté fascinant
disney c'est viens là et amuse-toi il ya
un côté obligatoire et totalitaire de
divertissement qui est extrêmement
angoissant j'ai appelé ça moi une fois
le goulag du bonheur parfaitement voilà
c'est le goulag du bonheur parce qu'il
est petit off qui nous a rejoint le
staff montois site off qui sera
d'écouler 1 semaine prochaine mais bien
s'asseoir dit avec nous que tu fais as
tu t'en vas à la maison ah c'était un
coucou bombard à samedi prochain titoff
ciao bella ciao
korbosly des mégacités qui ont voulu
transgresser ils ont bien eu raison
un peu la règle de disney ils ont foutu
balle ou de dully de la jungle pas du
livre de la jungle à la flotte et
lamballe où s'est fait virer parce que
les gestes qui faisait pour demander aux
secours ils n'étaient pas réglementaires
n'est pas censé faire ces gestes là
ouais c'est extraordinaire et pensez
aussi que ça rejoint mes épisodes d'ice
et c'est très cruel sont les ans et la
mairie c'est ainsi que depuis 1955 que
ces parcs à thème existe il ya un plus
tôt il ya toujours un plutôt de rechange
les mecs qui sont à l'intérieur ils
vieillissent et meurent mais les plus
tôt ils sont toujours là et que ce soit
à tokyo à paris un geste mais les gestes
sont aussi mondialisé
c'est
c'est le mc-21 toujours d'arriver plus
tôt donc chakouri une échelle sans moi
c'est bien ce que les gestes sont
mondialisés que tout ce qui se passe sur
le effectivement sur la bouffe comme
mcdo le big mac c'est le mexique à
chatou c'est exactement le même et puis
ça le livre a été très bien accueillis
non mais ça va ça se passe bien oui bon
l'idée de lancement du livre c'était
voilà alors il est marqué dans le
journal appelle moi il s'appelle moix
appelle moi avec son numéro de portable
vous avez eu 394 appel en trois jours
qui vous a appelé que des mecs
pratiquement pour sa section c'est
dégueulasse il s'est fait ça uniquement
bon alors ça fait alors un casque et de
quelles étaient leurs exigences c'était
beaucoup de lecteurs de têtu
par exemple et puis les journalistes
très curieux et puis la seule comptait
ce qui m'a appelé quand dire écoute j'ai
envie de toi immédiatement c'était trois
mecs du figaro qui m'ont fait une blague
a toujours autant de mal pour rattraper
parce que j'avais une émission qui
chouine est il disait même avec la
notoriété j'arrive pas à traverser il ya
un vice de forme qui fait que même si on
met dans la peau de mick jagger pendant
trois jours a fait trois jours de
râteaux séjour c'est en moi il ya un
truc
essayez mickey ouais mais c'est marrant
parce que quand j'étais au lycée etc
les rondes idée de certaines nana elle
c'est une [ __ ] à la couche avec tout
le monde moi quand j'arrive et je t'ai
le le mec dire que dehors soit allons un
peu trop soit un sourcil qui n'allait
pas soit une marge initiale de la
célèbre ce feuilleton
le problème jean marie lebon problème
c'est quand ma vie je vais rencontrer du
coup selon ta définition que des [ __ ]
non alors sérieusement vous pensez pas
que c'était un peu négatif ce coup du
portable parce que honnêtement le
cerveau et non mais c'est un peu détruit
le côté littéraire du livre cette promo
avec le numéro de portable dans le
journal on peut y perdre et les crises
et de la bonne littérature pas
véritablement parce que je vais pas
jouer le plan écrivain interactifs etc
mais il faut bien savoir que
contrairement aux acteurs ou chanteurs
etc
les écrits on n'a jamais de contact avec
notre public en asie mais si l'on fait
des signatures chez o m
oui enfin les signatures il ya 3500
personnes aux côtés de christine deviers
joncour lui dire madame j'adore ce que
vous faites c'est quand il parle des
fellations ou du contenu du livre et
puis alors moi j'ai deux personnes qui
viennent en me disant à quelle heure ils
arrivent frédéric beigbeder c'est un peu
comme beigbeder beigbeder le lancement
était tellement réussie que finalement
ça un peu nui à la qualité au côté
littéraire du lycée un peu passé comme
comme un pamphlet contre la pub alors
que quand même super bien écrit c'est
très bien parce que moi je suis à 100%
du côté de frédéric c'est qu'il y en a
marre du côté littéraire d'un bon
d'accord moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] du
côté littéraire on est là pour pour être
le même quels que soient les
circonstances et au téléphone rémission
de télé sur l'internet
si au cinéma macha enfin je veux dire
c'est un tout et le tout il voulait pas
jouer à l'écrivain ce que vous dites pas
du tout je veux pas faire des livres
littéraires etc
dans mes livres je parle de donald de
casimir de l'île aux enfants de grc
chaque camp dans l'île enfants c'est
tous les jours le printemps c'est le
pays joyeux des grands gérer dimanche 2
janvier c'est un bar à 10 16 euros
blaine down guns chanté par par michel
sardou dans les spectacles de la vas-y
vas-y extraordinaire parce que c'est
hitchcock est aigri par mireille way que
leur gueule des méchants qui est parole
et ces femmes qui chantent aussi la voix
de colargol assez mûrs et c'est moi qui
suis colargol ce qu'ils chantent enfance
en do dièse en mi bémol engine est au
faux col bleu roi des oiseaux vous savez
mes amis ben laden est un beau sifflets
préfères tu décris pluie qui tombe à
bôle richard c
c'est chanter les chansons deza renault
avec gainsbourg chanté des chansons des
chansons de renaud avec la voix de
jacques brel
jacques brel aurait très bien pu le
chanter laisse béton et que tu regardes
ça tout d'un coup tu pars au début mais
tu te dis mais [ __ ] j'y voyais
vraiment pu changer ça intéresse ma
fille moi j'ai une version de chapi
chapo par lou reed c'est un bootleg un
collector pizza il ya une ligne de basse
corniche satisfaction par lui ce jour là
alors dit moi je peux pas jouer donc
plus de femmes n'ont pas plus de femmes
n'ont même plus de râteaux ouais parce
que vous dit en fait en parlant du sec
j'ai tout devient normés et le sexe ne
fait pas exception
mais non il ya un truc qui est très
drôle c'est que je suis allé voir sur un
site de prostituées récemment c'est
quadrillé là je la fis son nom son âge
son numéro de portable
les spécialités les tarifs les horaires
et un truc fabuleux la tournée je
voulais me suivre et terra jeu c'est
fabuleux
alors vous avez des problèmes quand même
dans le premier livre qui s'appelait
jubilation vers le ciel vous écrivez les
premiers jours
hélène me refuse à son derrière son
popotin ventru moulés dans la braise et
un peu plus loin elle avait cru devoir
et c'est très bien mais j'avais cru
devoir exclure ceux d'hommes de sa bible
intime c'est plutôt bien écrit oui c'est
un ring la littérature ah bah elle avait
cru devoir exclure ceux d'adp de sa
bible ça doit beaucoup au pied du mien
quand même l'avouer et alors ça vous a
coûté le prix du premier roman au salon
du livre de bordeaux pourrait se dire
que le recteur de l'académie un tracteur
mais voilà la musique je parle de
recteur effectivement et il a refusé de
distribuer mon livre au lycée c'est
dingue alors grasset a donc mais ça ça
reste dans les annales des éditions
grasset pour qui enquille qui ont envoyé
le
un livre 28 mandats vous comme ça le
recteur la vie dans toute finale choc
obid ie8 disque j'avais alors vous savez
pas donner son avis alors oui oui
puisqu'on j'ai envie d'aider leur
philosophie
ovidie et anarcho punk et philosophe
vous étiez à la peau paris soit la
nationalité c'est à dire le contraire
mais je crois que son fils préféré c'est
le fondement de la métaphysique des
moeurs non non alors voilà un autre qui
est contre la fidélité alors lui il dit
moi qui dit l'homme descend du singe et
le bonobo n'a jamais été fidèle je suis
plutôt pour la fidélité ma théorie s'il
faut être fidèle à toutes ses maîtresses
adacore fidèles aventure voilà alors
vous avez des envies de cinéma vous
aussi regarder chesnais il a fini par
faire son film est donc vous vous
préparez un film s'appelle podium c'est
ça c'est ça
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui se prend
pour claude françois oui c'est un film
sur l'univers des saisies alors en ce
moment je suis en train de rencontrer
tous les saisies les ce drôle il est
saisi de cloclo et ses lauriers les
moments fantastiques ou un des sosies
officiels de claude françois dénigre un
de ses collègues en dix ans laisse
tomber aucune personnalité vous avez
déjà faire un court-métrage s'appelle
grand oral
c'est quoi le pitch le pitch est une
société dans laquelle tout est sujet à
examen ultra théorique avec la un
candidat arrive et on lui pour qu on lui
pose des questions ultra théorique sur
la fellation la sodomie etc et ensuite
il ya les épreuves pratiques et il ya un
jury extrêmement difficile délicat et
extrêmement pointue et ces jeux
pourraient réexaminer la technique de
dalons du doigt dans le cul s'il vous
plaît il ya également assez pas au
programme cette année donc c'est un truc
c'est désormais aussi oui voilà c'est
énorme mais c'est lena du de la vie
intime si vous voulez tous savoir c'est
pas la question
mademoiselle je vais vous demander de
tirer un sujet définition monsieur
le cunnilingus et bien mademoiselle nous
allons commencer par vous je vous prie
de vous asseoir quant à monsieur lui il
va passer au tableau noir new legend et
l'appareil génital féminin
j'ai gardé papier rien la fellation
aussi appelé rmation du latin rue main
st ce qui au sens propre signifie donner
le sein consiste à mettre dans la bouche
le membre en érection la verge ainsi
introduite doit être chatouiller soit de
la langue soit d'élèves et sucé qui
conclut près cet office est un fait la
theurre car ils sucent voilà jean bart
ça vous avez la visée on a reconnu julie
depardieu et françois berléand voilà
alors vous êtes client idéal il ya deux
mois pour un anti portrait chinois
attention et a dit on bouge prend
pendant le single pop réponse ne dit
rien du sort bien alors le portrait
chinois à ces sites étaient une fleur je
serai à myosotis lentilles portrait
chinois celle inverse
si vous étiez un défaut je serai la plus
grande qualité de mon pire ennemi
ouais c'est pas mal ça si vous étiez une
rupture je ne peux pas être une rupture
j'ai trop vécu j'ai pas envie d'en
devenir une une injure j'étais une
injure je serai fille de [ __ ] parce que
je suis pour la parité malade et si
j'étais une maladie je crois que serait
la maladie d'alzheimer parce que je ne
pourrais pas me souvenir que j'ai la
maladie d'alzheimer
un accident de concorde comme ça je fais
la une de tous les journaux dans le
monde entier pendant un mois une
perversion une perversion ça c'est
difficile je crois que je serai la
zoophilie parce que j'ai jamais
rencontré une tortue d'eau ou un cochon
d'inde me refuser un 69
une guerre une guerre va une guerre
lubrique c'est à dire une guerre de
position un vice si j'étais un vice je
serai un vice qui englobe tous les
autres vices le sexe parce que c'est en
même temps un jeu de hasard est une
drogue
une trahison j'étais une trahison je
suis déjà une imposture jeu peut en plus
être une trahison c'est une arme une
arme
si j'étais une arme attendez laissez moi
un peu et une arme si j'étais une arme
je crois que serait la culture parce que
quand j'entends le mot revolver je sors
ma culture très bien un supplice le
supplice de la baignoire parce que j'ai
envie de mourir proprement une cicatrice
une cicatrice
le nombril du monde un poison et un
poison
alors là un poison qui coulerait dans
les veines de george w.bush un [ __ ] tu
t'es un [ __ ] serait un gros [ __ ]
comme ça je pourrais sortir une grosse
[ __ ] qui lui est si vous étiez une
[ __ ] jeté une [ __ ] sur une cape une
fille capable de coucher avec and max
ouais un impôt un impôt sur le
sex-appeal comme ça je serai exonéré
ouais une panne bas une panne
d'inspiration qui frapperait tous les
écrivains qui écrivent plus vite que moi
un dictateur hitler il a écrit des
best-sellers avait investi l'air moi
j'ai pas réussi une infirmité une
infirmité
michel petrucciani parce que j'adore le
jazz and haas à sa guise de bord parce
qu'il a assassiné guy debord un microbe
un an ça me rendrait malade d'être un
microbe une plaie j'étais une plaie je
serai ouvertes toute la nuit
un fléau le sida parce que je suis très
people un terroriste je serai un
terroriste mais je préfère sauter des
bombes que les faire sauter pas mal une
torture une torture je serai l'avenir
parce que l'avenir appartient à ceux qui
se lèvent tôt et ça c'est une torture ce
veto une humiliation une humiliation une
humiliation
je crois que je serai une soirée avec
rocco siffredi dans une boîte échangiste
et une mort celle des autres bravo yann
moix ali ces accords comme chez grasset
entrée 6 e ht il faut l'acheter
moi qui viens alors maintenant mesdames
messieurs c'est le climax de cette
émission vous êtes prêts donc on a fait
un blind test spécial perle noire
donc ce ne sont que des chanteuses
noires exceptionnel attention didier
[Musique]
et pour animer le blind test et surtout
l'arbitré philippe corti
bonsoir fuite un art comme c'était perle
noire je trouvais que ça faisait un peu
tâche yonne l'émission a que des belges
avait des filles dans l'émission comme
ça année des filles c'est une très bonne
idée
attention vous me lance on joue par
équipe donc à l'équipe des oranje
on a l'équipe des bleus vous savez ce
que je vous demande c'est l'interprète
laurent baffie le sait je ne demande pas
le titre de la chanson je demande
l'interprète et ce ne sont que des
perles noires comme toi et les ballons
ok on y va didier meynard hausse
bon ben on a omis au midi avec la
frangine bravo ça y est on a besoin des
perles noires c'est génial on marque le
point d'accès logique a gagné bravo
merci deuxième chanson didier dinart
hausse des diplômes
j'en bave hollande
diana
et suprême je lis ton
[Musique]
bien bien bien alors pour le moment un
point de chaque côté un haut visible à
fives ou sauver l'honneur de vos équipes
respectives didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
noir c'est vrai qu'elle est bonne les
bleus deux fois les oranje un point mais
dans toi ma fille parce qu'il a dit de
foix jean rostand s'était pas aller
quand c'était l'a pas dit bon alors en
carton jaune on me dit un truc
attention soyons sérieux
attention monsieur didier gailhaguet
[Musique]
ouais
ah non non non je suis là combien
prouver que ce n'est pas truquée aussi
larbi peu partout vous jouez par équipes
attention là c'est beaucoup plus
difficile c'est la même chanson je veux
l'interprète
comment
si aulas
landis gyr
au saut
révélations
[Musique]
formidable comme dirait à lille est
formidable comme dirait gildas
magnifique comme dirait drucker
bravo et c'est toujours lui un et je
joue pour les oranje donc bravo tu joues
pour les oreilles
tu y es tu t'appelles comment éric il
s'appelle du jour est bien très bien ok
c'est le fond à la télé aussi et bien
alors on continue
bravo bravo donc ça leur ait 3 2 c'est
quoi la répond quelques clics on
continue la même chanson je veux
l'interprète didier énorme
je l'accomplis le quartier jackson le
public
ouais bravo tu l'as lu avant on le dit
avant ici ici avant
mais sa maman
je ne dois pas
10h02
danseur voir
je suis le premier ashton la première
place c'est moi qui l'a achetée alors
pas vrai
l'avant du grenelle m
qui a vendu une place inhabituelle six
pôles il a gagné le shell en afrique
il est génial à corti en blaxploitation
était vraiment génial ça l'est toujours
c'est ça oui c'est un truc voilà donc
les bleus 2 les oranje 4 ça va pas très
fort des orangers ballon s'il vous plaît
didier
[Musique]
for my baby just cares for me dinah
cimade l'homme
[Musique]
et bien si ce qui pousse en souffre le
bal public qui a dit donna summer ou dc
pour deux cartons et s'annule le point
dans l'ue salue le jeu sami la réponse
qui a dit sa quête du salut le jeu hu
dans les coupes yahia viens viens viens
maintenant qu allissa bien celle qui
vient certainement pas lui
[Applaudissements]
c'est top promotionnelle vichy bon ok tu
n'aurais pas dû dire ça pascal sellem
qui est sur scène avec laurent baffie
dans cette pièce jeux que je déteste
parce que non on continue didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention chanson numéro je sais plus
combien didier ça c'est dur c'est beau
mais c'est dur facile pas loin
l'activité guéret le groupe américain de
chance on entend le nom très gros noms
[Musique]
gfr
c'est le temps
vous
et oui mais les cherry qui est la fille
de john kerry le jazzman et qu'il a dit
dehors de la legal highs chili bravo les
enfants n'iront je connaissais tous une
année très riche et très bien chanson
alors 4 pour les bleus 5 pour les
oranges c'est très très très proche a
alors allons-y chanson numéro et c'est
normal le public ne souffle jackson
janet pour les bleus étaient donc
nombreux contacts dédiés
[Musique]
c'est une blague whitney houston
c'est quoi les mariale là
[Musique]
oh
les ballons
qui n'ont point qui a dit cheikh à
cahors
frattini
[Applaudissements]
et ici
sourds et des lexiques chaka khan pour
les bleus chaka khan dans le dos moi je
suis premier c'est vrai c'est l'enjeu
des saynètes et 4 pour les bleus 7 pour
les anges
didier la croisière s'amuse laurent
fragile
c'est une perle noire as a way
oh
le
non non non là j'y crois pull facebook
là j'y crois pas parce qu'ici j'ai cru
lie à ta famille tu as pas marre filer
plein de trucs mais jamais derrière
jamais ça je le crois pas je peux enfin
messieurs je divise
bon et alors maintenant maintenant c'est
très compliqué parce que celui enfin
seule équipe qui va trouver le titre à
l'interprète de la chanson qui vient
cette équipe a tout remporté je sais
c'est injuste mais la vie est injuste
c'est le super banco dj on ne souffle
pas si grand
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais
m
oui bravo l'ombre à merci bravo alors il
ya plus qu'une chose à faire avant la
fin de l'émission c'est le tatouage de
vie et ce tatouage de anglade
[Applaudissements]
les housses à toi je me dis alors j'en
ai deux à des gens qui attendent depuis
11 heures du soir pour voir le tatouage
de lui l'image montre le petit on veut y
aller au et sinon y'a pas moyen de jeter
un coup d'oeil sur le moteur merci au
vide et merci beaucoup
quoi qu s'était tout moment par attac
landes affiche au sexe magouille et
culture générale de la roumanie avec non
ma fille pascale sellem mado lambert
bien en plus d'argent par 6 9 septembre
[Applaudissements]
ces boudins panure de plus de temps j'ai
vu dans taxi n'est pas très bien et
beaucoup me l'enlever la bombe l'enlever
quoi bon bah fille à moi bah oui j'étais
je viens de chercher pour répéter
travailler maintenant au revoir
[Musique]
soins prenez-en soin ciao ciao challans
à lui didier nos batteries c'est que
l'agriculture général de et avec l'ompi
pascal sellem made man bien leur part si
jérémy menez gala au théâtre du gymnase
à partir du 30 janvier pour 100
représentations
jean hugues anglade merci mortel
transfert de jean jacques beineix avec
hélène de fougerolles y règne et au
viguier au midi
or j en noir de et avec le midi chez
marc dorcel productions anastacia
nasdaq/ice son dernier single est
régulée de l'album éponyme
jean marie bigard site internet officiel
www
w points bigard points comme didier
gustin
augustin mise en scène et co écrit par
jean marie bigard
anne-valérie noir une paumée perdre sa
fille que les élections éditions
flammarion
patrick chesnais un charmant garçon on
replie médicis de et avec patrick
chesnais avec alexandra vandernoot yann
moix
alyssa corto chez grasset voilà c'était
toulon en parle
rendez vous la semaine prochaine ouais
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
tha
non
[Musique]
m
il est menacé
[Musique]
m
tu es school
espagne
moi
m
[Musique]
non